e
good morning everybody uh welcome to
another day in education policy and
administration
committee um we have a full day of of
hearings uh today and uh house session
tomorrow so couple of busy
days um so our first bill today is House
Bill
662 requiring the discussion of abortion
procedures and viewing of a certain of
certain videos during health education
in public schools and uh the prime
sponsor I believe is here representative
you uh thank you chairman Celli uh
representative of the committee house
and policy committee thank you for
allowing move that a little
closer even even closer okay thank you
sorry about that thank you for the uh
few moments to talk and I won't take up
too much of your time but this I want to
present this bill um for multiple
reasons but anyways I wanted the general
court to make a decision on it and move
forward and it's it really is about our
our children and our kids
education the
uh the video that I actually sent the
entire committee last night would be the
videos that would be used uh in class
and these videos are uh educational
medically accurate comprehensive and age
appropriate our schools are not
providing our kids this information
which is uh important in making
decisions it is also important that our
kids have an accurate knowledge of for
the healthy relationship and a strong
society and here's a here's one fact
just so we know this is I think it's
necessary that they start learning this
it is estimated that 33% of uh women
between uh teenage years and also
45 uh will get an abortion
33% and out of those there it's
estimated 18% will be teenages and out
of out of that part uh and for 58% will
be in the 20s so this information is
necessary now and not later in their
life and I believe that this information
is information our kids really need to
know and understand what they're getting
into and how it may affect them our
school health uh class teacher instructs
our kids on many things including
abortion today and we should not allow
our kids to be ignorant or confused to
what takes place during the different
types of
abortions I can tell you in my district
they have a full SC schule I think it
goes for about 8 weeks and I mean it is
full I said I I I never had anything
like that when I was growing up and I'm
saying these kids are learning a lot but
occasionally we have snow days
assemblies and other things that will
distract from the class and therefore
one of the topics would be missed and I
would not want to see this topic to be
missed uh some may say that uh this
video or the videos here are to
graphic but I say we have many
questionable teaching and non-teaching
materials in our schools
today so you you you know is it too
graphic is not that's I guess you could
question it but I don't think it is
these are comprehensive completely
educational well done nonpolitical
non-religious V uh
videos I think both sides should be able
to get behind this and actually move it
forward Banning these Banning these
educational videos would be no than
Banning books and not allowing the
children to
learn there is nothing to hide really
nothing to
hide they're non-political and
non-religious I I hope that you would uh
ought to pass this bill 667 I I'm not
sure of the number now I apologize but I
hope you ought to pass this bill and I
appreciate I'll take any questions and
answer on the best I can uh thank you
representative questions from the
committee
yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um I might understand that this
is taking away local control for
curriculum local control for curriculum
materials yeah I that's my question uh
thank you for the question you could
look at it that way yes I look at it is
there are some things in life that need
to be consistent throughout our state
and this is one one thing I can see that
like I said earlier in our district
because of
different distractions that go on or
snow days or something else we don't
want to miss this topic and so that's
why I'm bringing it to the general court
so it's actually consistent throughout
the
state thank you yes represent Cornell
could you get into more detail about the
attorney general shall have standing and
have a cause of action to sue for
damages or relief on behalf when what
would cause that to
happen uh um could you repeat the
question I
apologize I I I'm want to know what the
Attorney General shall have standing as
parents Patria to enforce this section
on behalf of any or all res any are all
residents or citizens of New Hampshire
and the Attorney General shall have a
cause of action to Su for damages or
injunctive relief on behalf of any or
all residents or citizens of New
Hampshire against any person or entity
that violates this section so I'm seeing
that as the Attorney General on behalf
of my neighbor down the street who
doesn't have any children in the school
could bring suit against the Attorney
General would have to bring suit against
the school for that well yeah thank you
for the question and and again we we
have a lot of ifs there you know if you
know if you know it's it's possible if
it's possible to do this or if it's
possible to do that we don't know for
sure I mean
what you're saying could be true I don't
know at this point but I know that this
video a video set of videos were really
important that I think the it's more for
the school district to follow the law if
it goes into law that's what it's about
follow followup yes so you're saying
that if the school district doesn't show
this for whatever reason someone who
doesn't have a child in the school can
complain to the attorney General and Sue
the school for not showing
it uh again thank you for the question
the I would I would say yes you're
probably right all right but I'm not an
attorney so I don't know all right and I
think it would be no different than us
all of us paying taxes to our schools a
lot of us don't have children in
school thank
you further questions yes representative
Freeman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative CIS for coming before us
so um I wanted to know if you know that
does the state require that we have
education in all of our school
districts have what help does the state
require that we have health education in
all of our districts yes it does so and
may may I have a followup sure thank you
so there is no local control when it
comes to health education that was an
edict handed down by the state is that
correct that is that's my understanding
Accord going into the law right now
thank
you represent
Woodcock thank you chairman Cordell
um repres thank you for bringing this is
it your belief that the health care
providers that young women go to
seea uh fail to provide appropriate uh
advisement on their
options yeah thank you for the question
so interesting enough when I was just
doing an internet search which I know
everybody believes the internet is true
right um I was I actually landed on
plant Parenthood and all they showed or
all they provided in any video that I
could find out there was in clinic
that's all they talked about in clinic
all right as far as they didn't actually
dis they didn't actually explain the
different types of abortions or what
takes place during those so
you know it's it's it's not my belief
I'm just saying the it's not widely
known out there what actually takes
place follow up Mr chair yes well I'm
not talking about Planned Parenthood or
any other organization I'm talking about
when the young woman or woman a woman or
a family go to meet with their health
care provider the doctor is going to be
working with them through any process of
decision- making is it your belief that
those people don't advise them of what
their options are uh again thanks for
the question and of course I'm not there
with them so I don't know what they say
I really can't answer that just one more
followup CH thank you um and of all the
educational and I say this having been a
health teacher of all the educational
opportunities out there for youngsters
to see in schools to select how that you
selected this specific piece of the
video which are which are inflammatory
by the way what what they may be
accurate but they're inflammatory but
how did you happen to pick that specific
piece of the video to be seen uh your
expertise there again I you have to
start somewhere so I picked those to
start off with are there others that
could be just as good sure absolutely
and and I'm not saying they can't be
used either these are short animated
Well Done by
OBGYN doctors that have actually
performed abortions and stuff in the
past and they're actually doing the
narrating along with the anim animation
so they really done videos really done
very well and at this point here I don't
mind if you go with another one I mean I
can tell you that in my district the
healthc Care teacher uses a a video
that's about 40 50 years old it's you
know it's very well done and it explains
some of decision making that the kids go
through but that's them and then the
other thing is they actually use a TED
Talk when in the Ted Talk part it
actually goes in and actually actually
you can say it it touches on religion
even and in our case so they're using
other videos now to their advantage so
this video another video something
similar I'm not opposed to that thank
you thank here thank you representative
s thank you and thank you for taking my
question I'm I'm way over here on the
side on the other side of your speaker
so um I am trying to understand the
motivation behind the bill I I
understand that in our health classes we
want to make sure we're providing
students with accurate information about
what happens with their bodies about
what happens uh if they choose to be
intimate or if they are forced to be
intimate with someone and uh the
different implications of that but what
I am really struggling to find is the
why this has any necess
if our schools are already providing
health information and providing
accurate information to students why we
would be showing videos about specific
medical procedure are we also going to
show them about or arthoscopic surgery
which most of our high school students
or many of our high school students will
experience are we also going to show
about setting broken bones why do we
need specific videos and by a particular
company on this one I I don't I don't
get it again thank you for the question
and again a specific company with was
not on my mind I started someplace I use
these videos to start we could use other
videos I'm not against that that's not
what the it's about it's about they are
teaching and touching on abortion in
health class but that's all they do they
touch on it and right in 33% as I just
stated before 33% of young women are
going to get an abortion so this is
going to affect a lot of people and they
so they should know what it takes place
in the different types of procedures
may may I just clarify when you talk
about 33% and I don't know where you get
that information from is that um
including people who have ectopic
pregnancies who have uh fetal
abnormalities who have all sorts of
complications or maybe uh other causes
that are are because it is absolutely
100% medically necessary for them to
have a procedure like that including um
miscarriages that fail among other
things yeah thank you for the question
again and I can gladly uh share the link
with you um after the meeting once I get
back to my computer where I got the 33%
from it did not break it out by the
different procedures or or necess needs
that point um I have a question um in
Roman 3 Lines 14 and 15 uh talks about
grades 9 through 12 um they have to show
uh annually at least two two of these
three
videos is that at each
grade they have to show two of
those uh videos so that um uh grades 9
10 11 and 12 they would see two of those
videos each
year yeah uh thanks for the question
after I put the bill together I actually
was talking to the healthc Care teacher
in my district again and I understand
that there's only certain grades that'll
actually go through health class and at
that point the intent was that all four
grades 9 10th 11th and 12th would have
this every year that was the intent on
the bill now I understand that if
they're only required to have health
class once in those four years I would
expect that we could even amend this to
make sense that this is shown at least
once in those four years and of course
and just so it's already on file parents
are able to opt out that's not
changed thank you resident
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
again representative sellers
so this bill is not meant to sway or
influence young women in any way shape
or manner on whether to get an abortion
or not is that
correct no it's not it's it's non-biased
like that it's only informational and it
it doesn't carry Republican Democrat
Christian non-Christian it's not it's
just plain informational thank
you uh representative Woodcock and my
final question Mr chair yes um I'm
trying to think as a high school
teacher what piece of information we we
or video or book we repeat four years in
a row if we aren't trying to make a a
prejudicial statement I would suggest
you if you're going to run a video
requirement like that for 4 in a row
perhaps you should also do contraception
prevention four years in a row I wonder
why that was not part of your
bill um thanks for the
question uh I don't have an answer for
you it could it usually been I just
don't have an answer thank you Mr chair
represent Bon thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um are
you aware of in our any uh health and
wellness program in this state of uh
such a specific requirement um of
showing videos uh to illustrate any part
of the
curriculum I apologize I am hard at
hearing so I'm sorry um I'm just
wondering if in your uh research um
talking to health and wellness teachers
uh throughout the state if you know of
any requirement in health and wellness
classes that even requires showing
videos
uh thanks again for the question if
there's there's no requirement that I'm
aware of that says it has to be video
and material or any that whatever the
format wants to be it's up to the
teacher and even the style of the
teacher how she or he wants to teach is
totally up to
them follow
up um follow up just uh but but by doing
this you're taking away that ability for
the teacher to teach the curriculum in
the way that the teacher sees best fit
for the
students what you say pardon
me no if anything I'm hoping adding that
to the teachers say because some
teachers don't use videos at all so I am
asking if they would use this video all
right and of course there would be
discussion and material I would think
that would go along with
this represent Hall Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I just want
to make sure I understand you said the
you I watch these videos and you feel
that they are age appropriate I taught
middle school for 40 years I can't
imagine those eighth graders being ready
to go in and watch these videos that
were pretty graphic it I so my question
is you you stand by your words and
saying that they all these videos are
age appropriate yeah thanks for the
question these are not for eighth
graders it it says clearly 9 through 12
follow up yes I agree with that but I'm
just saying when those eighth graders
leave they're ready to go into in a
couple months to be in nth grade so that
was all that you feel at their age
appropriate yes I do okay thank
you see no further questions thank you
very much representative thank you uh
welper ni you again oh good to see you
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
for the record my name is Kurt welper I
am chairman of New Hampshire right to
life and I am here to uh
enthusiasm 67 million
babies have died because of abortion in
our
country since roow versus Wade
million this is the biggest human rights
China a lot of that comes
because the women get
pregnant and don't know what going
on uh my wife ran a uh Pregnancy Help
Center
for a number of
years around the
information but laws like ultrasound
laws um requiring the showing
of the results of an ultrasound save
baby's lives at the rate of around
70% 70% of the women who see those
videos change their
minds about
abortion that's an awful lot of women an
awful lot of babies that would be
saved the fact is that they people in
our country do not
know what an abortion
is they do not understand that the sole
purpose of an abortion is to
kill a human a living human who has done
nothing but be
conceived
Destiny it's an
atrocity and educating women on what is
involved when when I go to the
hospital for an heart surgery
the doctor explains to me what they're
going to
do they're going to stick stuff up my
veins they're going to burn parts of my
heart whatever they're going to
do when a women go for abortion this
does not
all when we talk about these things and
when I say we I even mean the medical
providers they're very precise about
what they talk about so if we're talking
about an operation that's going to kill
a child inside the woman they don't talk
about the
child they talk about the woman and what
the effects will be on
don't they don't tell the whole
truth I'm not saying they
lie I'm saying they don't tell the whole
truth because there's little to no
discussion of the long-term negative
consequences for the mother now that's
not part of this bill it's just because
I'm here talking about this I it this
always comes out
right if women
knew what was going to happen when they
went for an abortion very many were them
would not they don't and the reason they
don't is because it's not covered
anywhere and even medical providers
don't really talk about it in detail
occur and it's
a we're not for you could tie that back
to the bill so this is why we need this
education in the high schools because
women need to know what those operations
are they need to see
what actually happens they need to see
the babies trying to get away they need
to see the
results that's why we need it when they
see it they'll never forget it ever and
it'll save a lot of babies lives and a
lot of mothers a lot of
grief thank you very much questions from
the
committee see n thank you very much for
being back in
I have my written testimony here okay
fine uh good afternoon my name is Walter
the procedures that are involved in
abortion are not for the faint of heart
it's true given that it is estimated
that one in four women have had
abortions the topic can be extremely
triggering and therefore demands that we
treat it with the love and concern for
the students present giving them clear
Alternatives but nothing can change the
scientific fact that the goal of
abortion is is a dead
baby speaking strictly
scientifically chemical abortions use
two drugs on day one myth prone is used
to block the progesterone needed to
sustain the beginning of pregnancy if if
I could just um ask you uh to stick to
the bill itself not get into the uh
General topic of abortion yeah I
understand thank you young women also
need to know the truth about about how
abortion affects their bodies including
risk of bleeding and hemorrhaging
increased risk of uterine and breast
cancer and the possibility of sterility
or even death as is usually the case for
all major
surgeries many high schoolers and
college students who are pregnant before
they feel ready believe that abortion is
the only way out however the truth is
that there are many Pregnancy Resource
Centers in the state and that these
young women need to be informed about
life-saving options they offered to
support women from pregnancy through the
early years of Parenthood as well as the
option of
adoption members of my generation need
the truth to be able to make informed
decisions about our bodies and those of
our children I would minimally ask for
us to be given the education to make
sure that we know what our choices will
do to ourselves and to others
this is necessary to be responsible
intelligent and informed members of
today's society so I ask you to please
support HB 662 God bless you and thank
you for your
time thank you for being here uh
questions from the
committee see none thank you very much
thank
you yes if sir if you have written
testimony um would you be oh okay thank
you
antel excuse me Mr chairman Mr chairman
excuse me uh in view of the fact that
there are not sufficient copies for all
members of the committee we way we'll
sir I'm sorry thank you for being here
I'm sorry um I should probably mention
my son handed you all three of his
testimonies for the three different
bills so what you're seeing in front of
you is not just for 662 it's for the
other three he was nervous he's never
he's done this only once before that's
fine we appreciate uh we appreciate
firsttime testifiers and testifiers
alike yes thank you okay so hello my
name is Charlotte antall and I'm here to
662 there is no such thing as a life
without
consequences today's public school
health curriculum was constructed by an
Advisory board on which Planned
Parenthood and Affiliates take several
seats they believe that young children
need to explore their sexuality that for
minors experimenting with sex is natural
that concept contraception is safe and
effective and that abortion is a way to
achieve your dream
dreams that's not how it played out for
many of the young women I knew in high
school and college who conceived too
soon out of five only one had her baby
the others chose abortion and have
struggled with mental illness drug abuse
and cancer another lost two wanted
children to the fact that she had been
on the pill no one told her that her
body would need time to heal before it
could sustain a pregnancy
again as a trustee of New Hampshire
right to life since
2013 I have encountered many more women
who feel betrayed by the education that
they received and who suffer greatly
from their decision to abort some write
plays create art and travel to schools
and churches telling their story some
work in Pregnancy Care Centers to help
pregnant women in crisis to get the
medical care family counseling and
financial help that they need some pray
outside of abortion facilities offering
help to both moms and their
babies some come to the March for Life
as quiet witnesses to the scars of
abortion I've met traumatized health
workers who were required to participate
in abortions who wanted to save lives
not take them I've met women who wanted
children but in their youth were told
that iuds were a safe method of
preventing pregnancy and discovered they
were sterile when they had them removed
I've known women who were trafficked
only to be betrayed Again by Planned
Parenthood who destroyed the
evidence abortion Advocates failed to
mention that their babies would be
dumped at the conquered landfill the
contraceptives can be abor atient or
told them that they could just go on
with their lives like nothing happened
after they chose to end their child's
life
wrap this P Bill all feel betrayed by A
system that told them that their choice
would not matter this includes the
educational system these children these
women were telling their stories and we
have a duty to
listen we owe the Next Generation better
than we received keeping our youth
compassion minimal they have a right to
know the truth about abortive patient
drugs surg surgical procedures their
very real risks and the aftermath of
abortion we owe it to them to tell them
the truth that their choices will have
lasting consequences no matter what they
choose but they need to know that
self-control never hurt anyone that
self-sacrifice for the good of others is
real love and that they can achieve
happiness even with a child in toe
please support HB 662 to ensure the next
generation gets the truth about
abortion thank you very much any
questions from the committee see none
thank you very
much and I believe that is the last card
if there's no one else who wishes to
testify I think we have uh one more late
my apologies Mr chair for U no problem
being a late entry I thought there were
a stack of cards so uh Jerry FW the
associate executive director of the n
school administrators Association I'm
here today to raise several questions
legislation first um and I I was the
first three bills of the day are
speaking about health education and I I
will speak you the aggravation of
listening to me three times and try to
consolidate into this one testimony our
concerns of of those bills so thank you
for that
opportunity this is a very prescribed
curriculum um eroding local control
decisions on what is best for local
communities and um the prime sponsor in
his testimony even indicated perhaps
that there were additional or different
Avenues to achieve the same purpose so I
would
um I would just remind the committee of
that that perhaps the the one video
cited isn't the only way to achieve the
legislation some members um to
representative Freeman's question about
health education standards yes the
health education standards are included
and in fact were most recently invi uh
revised uh by the State Board of
Education uh I do believe that none of
the three topics that are listed in
today's uh first three bills uh abortion
adoption or gestation are part of the
new standards for health education uh in
the they call the 306s the 306 rules I
don't believe any of those topics are
addressed in the curriculum standards
that have been recently approved by the
Education some of the members of
this body have legislation uh around
what constitutes an adequate
education health education has been
eliminated from some of those proposed
definitions of what constitutes an
adequate education what happens to this
bill should that bill pass and health
education is not required as part of an
adequate education in the
definition this committee
a few days ago approved uh as ought to
instruction I would
invite committee members to explore the
proposed videos of that uh have been
provided to you uh by the prime sponsor
to explore and confirm what
evidence-based instruction has been
included in the production of those
videos to representative Hall's point I
was a middle school administrator for 15
years the legislation calls for
college I challenge each of you to think
back to the days when you were 13 or
14 and then fast forward to the days
that you were or
18 developmental changes take place
during those
years health education curriculum is
typically in most high schools offered
uh as a course either in grade n or
grade 10 so basically you're talking
about 13 14 or 15 year
olds um being experiencing these videos
in any of the legislation so again I
invite you to think back to to those
days um or those of you who may be
blessed to have children or
grandchildren who are age 14 and think
about how they might process the very
see often times I sit in this room
listening to people a sale public
education and poor math scores poor
language art scores and poor science
scores and basically poor poor
scores yet we continue in this body and
others to talk about additional
requirements placed on public school
curriculum expectations where does the
time come from for all of these
question Public Schools already have a
pretty full plate of things curriculum
decisions are best made at the local
level with locally elected officials and
those folks that are um picking up the
tab if you will uh I did some research
on this and there are some states who
have uh actually there's no States who
who require this uh particular set of
videos but there are states who pay more
for adequate public education who uh
require certain pieces of of um
instruction New Hampshire is not one of
those States who rank high in their
support of public education uh through
um I guess I would say that if this if
uh this bill is not um deemed
inexpedient to
legislate as we believe it should be
that at least it be retained so that
more work can be done to make it a
better bill um and uh make it less
prescriptive
uh perhaps change the age
requirements you know
um but I just want you to understand
that requiring this bill um to be taught
in health education classes is um at the
Freshman and sophomore level is
particularly
challenging thank you very much thank
you questions representative M thank you
Mr chair and thank you once again for
your testimony I always appreciate your
perspective
in regard to the free videos selected
the prime sponsor did send them to us
and I did have the chance to watch them
I thought they were very thorough very
excellent however the prime sponsor
noted that he would be willing to say
not these particular videos but there
may be other videos available and I
would say that goes into what you
mentioned about local control would you
be more willing to support this bill if
it said um School District shall show
videos which may include these but may
include another topic or something along
those lines
thank you for the question
representative
McDonald uh the the question that I
would raise is is it part of the what
the state has determined what what
health education standards have
determined as part of what kids and
health education classes need to know
and be able to do and so if the State
education standards require that then I
believe um that there would have to be
materials and and I would also suggest
suggest that by retaining the bill the
committee could meet with health
Educators and let me just say students
we have a a state school board this
legislature a couple of years ago passed
a requirement for school boards to have
student Representatives on school boards
why not engage in conversation with
student representatives of school boards
about what they think would be
appropriate as part of their education
not what necessarily a whole bunch of
adults think is appropriate for their
education thank you thank you
representative yes representative s
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question um based on the
newest 306 rules which I haven't had
time to parse through all of them yet me
neither um and and maybe you would have
to get back to us with the answer maybe
one of the other people in the room may
have this in our current health
curriculum which I know my child had is
a ninth grader um when they discuss
reproduction and the reproductive
process is um the labor and delivery
process as well as
um abortion as well as contraception as
well as abstinence all included in that
curriculum or is it purely um that
people should be free to explore their
sexuality as uh someone previously
testified thank you for the question
representative I would have to get back
to you on that answer I uh I don't know
what the current standards speak
to representative Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my
question I want to get back to the
attorney general she have cause of
action to Sue I don't know if you read
that part of it if you have any thoughts
but I'm I'm thinking now the Attorney
General will sue if a school doesn't do
something that's not in the 306 plans
that they've been told to do thank you
for the question representative Cornell
it's like you read the testimony that I
forget to deliver the piece of um I'm
always concerned with any piece of
legislation that has a punitive
component that contains more money than
uh the opportunity for providing the
resources that teachers and students
would need to achieve the purpose of the
legislation uh when the state is
appropriating certain monies uh for
adjudication but not appropriating money
to provide resources training and uh
materials for kids that might be needed
to support this legislation that is a
point of concern thank
you representative Woodcock thank you
chairman good good
morning just a question did did I I just
want to make sure I heard I think I
heard what you said um in your testimony
did you just say that as far as your
research went that no states require
specific videos that you're aware
of thank you for the question
representative wock I believe in my very
brief cursory View and uh when I brought
up on a national conversation the other
day there were no States in that
conversation that have um and that was
over 25 States okay thank you thank you
CH thank you very much for your
testimony thank
Wilson uh good morning chairman cordelan
members of the committee for the record
Becky Wilson from the New Hampshire
school boards Association um we have
signed an opposition to this bill we're
not going to give a lot of further
testimony I just wanted to um answer the
representatives questions about the 306
rules that were just passed um the
health education program is covered in
section
30640 which has been updated as of
January 9th of this year um and that
will lay out for you the aspects of the
school health education program that
have been approved by the state Board of
Education um I will just also add that
over the past several sessions we've had
multiple highly prescriptive curriculum
bills which have not moved forward um
from this committee or the previous
House Education committee um this bill
certainly and the bills following are
extremely prescriptive um and I would
just fall back on some of the things
that I know Mr F has already covered so
I won't go through those again happy to
take any questions uh thank you for the
information
questions see none thank you very much
thank you and with that we'll close the
hearing on House Bill
662 and um in a
minute okay we'll take a five minute
break and we are going to uh adjust some
um clerical duties also at during that
time
yeah can
you you
first
e
we're just about set to uh
resume and we will resume with House
Bill
667 um which is relative to health
education and requiring the viewing of
certain videos demonstrating gestational
development from embryo to fetus through
Birth by public school students and
college or university students and um
welcome back representative
sellers thank you Mr chair and committee
members again thank you for your time my
name is representative John sers Grafton
Bridgewater baby Olivia is a medically
active
animated glimpse of the human life from
the moment of fertilization this story
details her growth as she
progresses from the development stage to
the next in preparation for her
continued life outside the womb why I'm
bringing this to the general cord it has
an educational value the video provides
a detailed visual representation of the
baby's development which is a which is
crucial which is a crucial aspect of
human biology the baby Olivia video
serves as an invaluable educational tool
it offers a clear and engaging visual
visual representation of the stages of
human development from the fertilization
to birth this is not just a lesson in
biology but is all but an opportunity
for our students to gain a deeper
understanding of the human body's
Incredible
Journey it also does uh empathy and resp
respect for Life by showcasing the
development of the pre-born baby the
video helps Foster a sense of wonder and
respect for a human life it allows
students to continue emotionally to
connect emotionally with the subject
matter prompting empathy and compassion
towards the pre-born
children this in turn can lead to more
thoughtful and respect respectable
decisionmaking in their personal lives
it also provides uh informed decisions
informed decisions the video equips
students with the knowledge they need to
make informed decisions about their
reproductive Health in the
future understanding the complexities of
pregnancy and Fetal development is
essential for both young men and women
as they transition into
adulthood critically thinking in
debates moreover incorporating this
video into our curriculum can spark
valuable classroom discussion and
debates it en it encourages students to
think critically about ethical moral and
scientific aspects of human life and
development such discussions are vital
for developing well-rounded informed
citizens in
conclusion in conclusion the inclusion
of baby of meet baby Olivia video in our
school curriculum is not just about
teach teaching biology it's about
fostering
empathy promoting informed decisions and
encouraging critical thinking I ask you
to support HP
667 and help provide our students with
this non-political non-religious
comprehensive educational on pre-born
human development thank you uh thank you
very much uh questions from the
committee represent
thank you representative sellers for
bringing us forward and for showing us
those videos as well over email my
question is that this bill amends RSA
193e by inserting after section 3F a new
section that would be section g and the
previous Bill also is the same section
so if both were to pass does one
override the other or how would they
work if they're both the same section
yeah thank you for the question it's if
they both pass one be become G and
wonder hi
G the next word what is H I need go back
to school yeah I I think um it's the
last uh bill that passes um that
language unless there's a modification
uh an amendment to the bill got it thank
you um represent s did you have a I did
uh thank you sorry excuse me excuse me
sir
sorry I was uh disconcerted for a moment
sure yes um thank you and thank you for
taking my question so um I have two two
questions one is just looking at the
live action site it it talks about its
stance on attempting to change people's
minds and
perspectives and you're claiming that
it's a
nonpartisan
nonjudgmental or whatever all the
various adjectives so um if they State
on their website that their goal is to
change people's minds and perspective
Ives um doesn't that indicate they are
taking a specific
stance yeah thank you for the question
uh so any case again I have to start
somewhere I'm not necessarily saying it
needs to be their V video there's also
uh an endowment for human development
which has a similar video uh which is
absolutely neutral and I think it's
either 5 minutes or 9 minutes long so we
could use that one as well ask follow up
and I noticed that you're adding in
addition to saying that this should
happen in high schools that this should
be a requirement for University students
and my understanding is that although I
was not yet an adult when I arrived at
University the majority of people when
they get to University are adults and
shouldn't they be able to make the
decision for themselves about whether or
video yes you would think so uh these
are uh state universities and State
community colleges so the state has the
right to say what they should or
shouldn't be
doing representive Hall thank you for um
allowing me to speak and thank you for
taking my question could you speak to
the tens of thousands of dollars that
this is in the fiscal note what you know
what that's
for I can only say the fiscal notes are
estimates right I they're estimates I
mean a lot of they just don't know how
much things will cost they put something
in there follow up yes uh in here it
does say that the um community college
system uh there's an estimate but
there's this 10 to 100,000 per year on
top the university system said um
so so my question is does that seem like
a lot of money we're showing a video uh
to me it is a lot of money and that's
why I believe it's just an estimate I I
can't believe it costing that much but
again I I don't know it's thank you it
doesn't seem right a represent
Woodcock thank you
um represent I'm sure you're well aware
that New Hampshire's University system
is the least funded out of 50 states in
the bottom
and that this additional cost to the
least funded University system in this
St is a problem my concern about the
university system is my question is that
you're asking for mature adults who are
over 18 years old to pay money to go to
college to sit there and watch a
three-minute video and then have the
university certifi that before you can
graduate you watch a three-minute
video that's what this bill says is that
was that your intent
the yes uh thank you for the question so
the intent is for every person entering
the university system or Community
College would see that video at least
once throughout their time being
there and
follow and if somehow the they don't
watch that and the university can't
certify that they don't graduate from
college they don't watch a three-minute
video on biological development again
this is no this would be no it's three
minutes when you actually do all your
paperwork signing into the Community
College you would look at that video for
3 minutes and it would be done it would
be all signed off just question to
clarify my my question is if they don't
watch that are you're saying that these
people cannot graduate from
college that's what I put in the Bill
thank you resent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative sellers for coming um in
front of us again so um knowing that all
freshmen have to take
orientation would this not be a good
video to put into that freshman
orientation and thank you for the
question and that would be perfect that
would be the exact time it should be
there um representative Bon thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um all other areas of
curriculum there is an opt out function
um that serves so that parents might
decide that they don't want their
children and in these grades to be able
to um to watch these videos and also if
you're an adult why shouldn't you be
out I didn't put that pres um pres I
sorry see no further questions thank you
very much thank you um I think we'll uh
limit uh testimony to 3 minutes uh for
everyone and that seems to be what is uh
on the cards that uh I have in front of
me um so we will uh check that time and
next uh call up representative Paige
bman if I pronounce that close to
correctly thank you Mr chair and yes it
was very close Bosman you said it slow
but it was right thank you to the
committee for having me here today um my
name is Paige bman I am a representative
from nasua I represent nashua's Ward 4 I
am here as a health care provider as
well as a parent I am a women's health
nurse for the last 15 years I work in a
sexual Wellness Clinic where I educate
patients as well as being certified as a
sexuality education excuse me as a
sexuality educator for grades K through
12 so I am here with that perspective I
will tell you that I did not watch the
movies um and the reason is because any
specific video should not be legislated
so whatever the video is I don't know
that that's in alignment with evidence
base with what the best curriculum would
be um the the this should be shown any
movie should be shown in context of the
rest of the curriculum with the students
in mind in terms of their maturity
levels their emotional health it needs
to be tailored to that audience and only
the instructor can do that it might be
different from school to school from
grade to grade from class to class it is
completely inappropriate to legislate
what a child would see now I don't think
anybody here would agree that a math
teacher should be writing English
curriculum or that someone in this room
should be writing mental health
curriculum the same goes for sexuality
education we should leave it to the
experts there are people who have
advanced degrees in this there are
people who have master degrees in
sexuality education there are Physicians
there are nurses Nurse
Practitioners we know how to write this
curriculum because that is what we do um
we use neutral scientific evidence-based
materials because we have access to them
and we know what the resources are I
would also like to say um as a parent I
agree with that option um what what was
brought up about opting out there's no
way I would ever allow my my own
children with the expertise that I have
to watch something that came about in
this way and I don't want my kids
missing school that day because there's
no option for an opt
out that's it for now thank you so much
thank you very
much repr clug thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question you mentioned
the word neutral do you believe that
this bill is
neutral having seen the wording of baby
Olivia and and um and have I've heard a
few things about the video admittedly I
have not seen it um but what I've heard
even in this testimony is language that
is not generally considered neutral
language we the the best thing we can do
in sexuality education is prevent
present facts um and what one other
thing um is um excuse me I'm so sorry
um this of this information is already
included in sexuality education classes
in an appropriate way there's nothing
here and and that's because we want to
give the science behind it and so all of
this is already covered in most programs
and yet we have a huge fiscal note to
dictate something that is not
evidence-based and is already being
provided thank you thank you rep cic
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um my high school senior is currently
doing a dual enrollment class in child
development um and in the fall semester
a large portion of that was in fact
talking about the development from
gation actually pre- gestation um
because they had to look at you know how
sperm and egg happened to meet to create
gation as part of their curriculum about
it all the way through and they're now
working on the next level of Child
Development do you think it's essential
to have a video of any kind in order to
teach those skills or do you think that
there are other um materials that are
already in existence and already being
used either by Child Development
teachers or by Health Educators in the
school the high school level to cover
those topics without videos being
essential thank you so much for that
question um yes there are other videos
that exist and there are lots of other
materials um personally I have taught um
in a fifth and sixth grade uh sexuality
education class as well as currently I'm
teaching seventh and eth grade we go
over the stages of fetal development and
we do it with illustrations that can be
labeled um and so that's just one
example but as I said I'm not opposed to
videos um I think again that the
instructor needs to decide what is most
appropriate for the students in that
class and that's what I do as an
educator represent Terry yes uh thank
you so as you have uh read had reviewed
and spoken to the bill and um uh
evidently um understand the concern
expressed by the uh sponsor I just want
to be clear that I'm hearing you say as
a health educator that you believe that
the concerns that are expressed in this
bill are already adequately covered and
therefore it would be uh redundant in in
one sense and in another sense um the
the videos themselves are really not
necessary because you're already
including materials that would cover the
same topics and concerns that are
included in the
videos thank you for that question
representative I would say of course I
am not privy to every single sexuality
education course being delivered in the
state what I can say is that best
practice and the standard of this
education absolutely includes this I
don't know how you would teach somebody
about the reproductive system without
covering gestational development so that
would be my assumption unless it's a
very low quality program uh R
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for coming in front of us
so I you you mentioned that you thought
the language um was not considered
neutral can you point out any specific
thing that led you to believe that the
language wasn't
neutral absolutely if you just let me
take a look here
um even just saying meet baby
Olivia is making an assumption in some
and I know this is debate um but making
an assumption either way about calling a
baby a baby already is not
scientific and so that does skew in a
certain
argument thank you quickly please yeah
yeah actually I I I I um I yield thank
you very much thank you thank you very
much for your
testimony
Walter hello
again I'm Walter I am a clump of cells a
former fetal anomaly a high school
student and an aspiring parent and I
would like you to support HB
667 now why do I say I'm a clump of
cells because I am the human body is a
majestic thing and when we are in our
mother's womb that is no different the
science of prenatal development is an on
inspiring process Which is far more
important than frogs and clouds to the
average high
schooler in school we study how cells
work we study the formation of plants
and reproduction and the reproduction of
the tiniest forms of life such as
viruses and bacteria it follows that as
humans we need to learn about our own
species earliest development prenatal
development is an established science
and should not be reserved for those
studying
medicine cellular
reproduction serves as proof that any
other organism is alive it is also true
of humans at their earliest
stages basic embryology demonstrates
that human zygotes
are
alive that they are the first diploid
cell of an organism which carries the
full genetic information for that
individual these cells feed grow and
reproduce in the 1970s ultrasound
imagery made it look as if we were a
strange blob in a pocket of
fluid today we can see things in great
detail using 4D
ultrasounds you using today's Imaging
doctors can see that by 7 weeks
gestation the beginnings of the human
form the head the eyes and the hands
become clearly visible by 8 weeks they
can see the baby's heartbeating by 12
Weeks the whole human form is visible
the babies have all of their organs and
they just need time to grow and to get
stronger it has been shown in prenatal
surgeries and early abortion procedures
that babies as early as
a
yeah to exact we have here pleas yes
thank you yes please keep this to the
bill
okay as an aspiring dad I want to know
the truth about my future children's
development to make sure that they can
live the best life possible as a former
fetal anomaly I think it's important for
my generation to know the technologies
that doctors use to perform Sur iies on
Tiny children in the womb who may be
developing abnormally this may help to
demystify disabilities and to show how
new treatments love and support can make
fetal anomalies less scary I ask you to
pass HB 667 so that students like me
will not be denied the truth about how
our bodies are formed and how our
children will be conceived grow and
develop from conception through birth
knowing how we are created gives us all
a greater appreciation for life for
courageous women who bear us into the
world God bless you and thank you very
much for your time thank you any
questions see none thank you very much
thank you um next is Sarah
mcneel and let's everyone try and keep
our comments the testimony to the bill
itself not on a broader uh topic um that
can be addressed uh maybe in future
legislation so let's stick to the bill
please uh good morning um representative
quid allei and um
committee my name is uh Sarah mcneel I'm
a parent and a recently retired
registered nurse I volunteered as a
court appointed special advocate for
abused and neglected children I did that
for a number of years I also worked for
a number of years at the um at a clinic
that performed
abortions um before and after the
abortion I was with the client
I strongly oppose House Bill 667 for
several reasons this three-minute video
which I did watch entitled meat baby
Olivia is clearly geared toward
indoctrination of a young minds calling
an embryo a baby and giving it a name
baby Olivia is totally misleading and
likely to be confusing to some
children I want to interrupt my what I
had written initially because some of
this testimony was written in part
because of the article in the newspaper
which was addressing this to grade
school children also not just 9th grade
and on so some of that indicates
this um another reason is the video
states that quote life begins at
fertilization and also says when a new
human being comes into existence many
would disagree with that statement given
their own religious and scientific
backgrounds there are several
inaccuracies about the gestational
development but I will leave that to
Physicians to
address however using words and phrases
such as quote
fertilization or spontaneous reflexive
movements and uter even the word uterus
are likely words not understood by some
children also this V video uses words
and phrases such as touching her face
sighing stretching playing and exploring
unquote which are also misleading as
being purposeful functions and also
addresses the viability of the fetus at
various developmental stages that just
is not
true following a showing of this video
this is something I think everybody
needs to think about who's going to be
responsible for answering the questions
that these children may have these
students may have your young student
might say how did that baby get inside
the belly there's a lot of adults that
still don't know that but it it could
happen or uh will that will I have a
baby inside me at some point as I said I
was addressing more of a younger child
on this uh or what if I don't want a
baby inside me the way this video is
it's just a miracle of life it's going
to happen it doesn't even mail is never
mentioned at all it's just a miracle
that happens in in inside presumably a
woman's body an older child might ask
what does feralization
mean um just a couple things I um so
that was the questions who's going to
answer these questions my last thing was
in this bill it is mentioning that the
video will be shown to public school
children what about children that are
homeschooled or children that are in
private schools which seems to be more
and more an of an emphasis these days uh
what's going to happen about all these
children are they just not going to be
educated about the facts Al life or will
be left to their parents which probably
is the best way to do it
anyway I thank you I thank you very much
for your time thank you any questions
see none thank you very much for your
testimony I do have copies of it great
thank you very much that was appreciated
by the clerk in
particular
uh thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee again I am Kurt whoer I'm
chairman of New Hampshire right to life
and I'm here in full support of this
bill there's been a lot of serious
questions asked and I get I'd like to
give a couple my answers to a couple of
those questions one of them we just
heard was already a bias or or
or sounded like political uh
orientation in terms of the the this
video and what I can say to you is that
in my viewing of that video there is no
such thing even the ex the example of
misapplication of
terms my
understanding those were not inaccurate
they may not be what we call
scientifically correct in the sense of
a
baby and using that
term but all the terms that we use to
describe
humans from conception until death are
simply markers of one thing or
another they all describe the same human
being the same the baby is a fetus the
baby is this we become adolescents we
get old we become now whatever that is
all these adjectives that we use or or
synonyms are synonyms for the same thing
that's the human being who's the object
of abortion and who are being killed by
the millions in terms
of
so this bill simply presents asks that
public school children and I would agree
know about the miraculous development
that
occurs during a
pregnancy and I used her miraculous
carefully I saw that video I was amazed
at what happens at several
days I wasn't surprised by what happens
at several weeks or months I'm not very
familiar with those and I
children love this
information they just love it and will
they ask difficult questions yes but
there's an answer call that's above my
pay
grade it's not within this just like
what you're right now you're not talking
to that bill when you get to the college
level I do agree there probably should
be an opt out but this is a
question that the law deals with all the
time right for whom do we mandate and to
whom do we give freedom to object so if
that's where the community thinks it
should go put it
in but it's just as important all the
way through and the video is not the
idea of calling baby
Olivia um yeah it's
prejudicial in the sense that the whole
video is prejudicial toward the value of
human life and our respect for it
which by the way is a fundamental
Foundation of all of Western
Civilization so if you in
favor of keeping humans alive innocent
humans now that makes you biased
politically something no I urge you to
support the Bill thank you questions
representative wock thank you CH just a
clarification I want to make sure I
heard you accurately representative and
two comments I wrote down at I could
have screwed up you know I'm getting um
that you said that that some of the
terms in the video may not be accurate I
think that's what you I wrote down as
aot the argument against those bills is
that they're not used in the way that uh
medical professionals or
scientologists people who study these
things use them which is fine we don't
talk in about those in those terms those
terms i' I've seen plenty of videos I
understand I just question I just
repeating what you said okay the second
one I want to make sure I was correct he
said the video is not the video is
prejudicial yeah absolutely okay thank
you any further questions see none thank
you very
P thank you I'm Judy milary from Warner
I'm a retired Public School educator I
served 22 years as a principal in um the
towns of Newport and Grandam and Warner
and I had the
um privilege and the wonderful
experience of uh observing how life is
taught in K through way um
the the idea of a video
um is something that teachers do use but
in the early grades um Hands-On
learning um you know taking a direct
role in learning is so much more
valuable uh I saw kindergarten um
usually K the primary grades
kindergarten through three uh they would
teachers would have incubators and they
would hatch baby chicks sometimes baby
ducks one teacher actually was
successful in an aquarium in in raising
baby
frogs um this this is something that
teaches gestational development in a
very meaningful way to Little Children
um they chart the 21 days of the embryo
developing they candle the eggs um and
you can imagine how excited they are
when they hatch uh then empathy just
decision making these children care for
these baby chicks um and the families
are involved it's a very exciting way to
teach it's also a very developmentally
appropriate way I think that
teachers are experts in knowing the
materials to use knowing uh how their
children think how they learn and this
kind of experience is something
meaningful and Lasting and does so much
more than simply showing a video thank
you thank you any questions see none
except for representative Woodcock thank
you Mr chairman appreciate the ability
to clarify here principal thank you
welcome just a quick question in your
multiple years of being an educator and
principal have you ever seen uh valid
instruction that does not have a Q&A
after a
video well thank you for that question
um good teaching always has Q&A after
after every lesson especially videos
they need to be discussed in order to be
understood and thank you repr celic
thank you I just I didn't hear you say
specifically are you in favor of or
opposed to this bill and I just wanted
to make sure I make Mark and I may have
missed it because I was C make sure I
marked that I should have started with
that uh I am against Bill 667
thank you very much for your
testimony and the final card that I have
anel so in an effort to um keep things a
little more Bill oriented and uh I'm I'm
going to have to shove a little bit of
what I had planned to say and um and go
a little bit more based on my experience
so I should have probably mentioned that
I am a career educator I've taught eight
years in high schools and um also been a
uh Faith formation director in my Parish
I've dealt with um kids who
have been from all walks of life um my
first job was a uh an inner city all
girls catholic
institution we would um
discuss just about everything because
they're
girls and um and one of the things that
we uh delved into was prenatal
development as well as um IV f um
abortion and uh I had the privilege of
teaching the very first test Tu
baby in
Delaware um at that school and I and I
wanted I bring this up and it just kind
of hit me that I should bring this up
here
because there was no kid in that school
who had a better sense of how loved she
was and who she was as a human being
than that little girl it just wasn't
because she had her mother's Journal
about the whole experience all the
things she suffered all the money they
paid all the
sacrifices that they went through and it
was difficult for me as a teacher to
then go to her and say but you
understand how the process works and
there are some ethical problems with
that and I met with the parents and I
walked them through how I plan to teach
it um we set up debates we talked about
the issues kids were allowed to do
research on fetal development when it
develops properly as well as when there
are fetal anomalies both of my kids had
fetal
anomalies and I was given my
options which just horrified me because
everything is so streamlined now to make
it so that women can report for any
reason without even counseling you know
up at Dartmouth they they H I know that
up at Dartmouth they gave me a sheet of
paper that just said fetal anomaly with
a code and that was my counseling I got
it in the in the
mail that was after my ultrasound so I
bring this up because I am very diff I'm
very concerned that we offer children a
standardized education we are concern
concerned about standardizing education
in every other realm except this one
this is the one where everybody fights
back because they don't want the words
to be used the fact that an a zygote
becomes an embryo becomes a fetus
becomes a baby becomes a human they are
all the same so I I I need to know that
you guys are invested in giving our
children the truth thank you very much
any questions
questions thank you very much and with
that we'll end the testimony on House
Bill
667 and move uh directly to House Bill
730 which is requiring school districts
to educate and provide information to
students regarding adoption during
health education for grades 9 through 12
and in college in certain
circumstances and um once again
representative sers thank you uh thank
you Mr chair and committee members
represented cellers Grafton 10 Bristol
and
bridgew I'm bringing this bill forward
because information is powerful and if
you have that information you can make
right or decisions what you think are
right or wrong ones if you don't have
the
information so knowing that are
our teens and young adults are sexually
active and and could end up with an
unexpected pregnancy I would want them
to know that this information's out
there and a lot of them don't know they
don't know they don't even know where to
get the information or where it is or
it's out there now this one doesn't
require any video it's just information
and again this one looks at if there's a
if they're doing a um a clinic if I
remember the bill correctly that they
would provide this at this
point the other reason I'm bringing this
up too is and I'm not going to keep this
long is that there's 36 families waiting
for every sing every one child to be
adopted I mean people are waiting a long
time to be adopted and these kids at
least will have an option to their
unexpected pregnancy knowing that they
could have have someone else adopt their
baby and even
today there are there are many types of
adoptions but the the two of the most
common is are called open and closed
adoption an open one of course is you
know where your child is going and you
may have more interaction throughout the
child's years of growing versus a closed
you don't know anything about the
adopted parents or where your child has
gone so having this information I
believe is very powerful
for the kids at this point from grades 9
College I can only say the number of
waiting families for adoption continues
to
rise there are people that want these
babies thank you and I hope you'd
support HB 730 thank you very much
questions representative SEL thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm just looking at this saying that
it's going to be a minimum of an hour
discussion related to adoption are we
prescribing that level of um State
control over any other area of
curriculum mandating specific numbers of
hours or minutes to talk about a single
individual topic whether or not it's
appropriate for the students in front of
us uh thank you for the question I don't
know if we mandate exactly the time
frame I don't know that however uh
thinking back and looking at this I know
there's a lot of class um time that's
either in 40 minute segments or I
believe a uh an hour and 20 minute
segments so can I follow yes is it
therefore your assertion that the state
should make a determination about the
specific amount of time any given
subject is taught as opposed to leaving
that to local control and local decision
makers the point I was trying to thank
you for the question the point I was
trying to make is that the the the kids
out the student students need to have
time to understand and also there's a
lot of information out there on adoption
and then and my point is is that they're
going to be talking as question and
answers will probably take up that
hour so
yes representative
Murray thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question representative um
within the bill you enumerate that you
believe the Attorney General should have
some sort of
jurisdiction uh through parents
on enforcements of this issue what
impact to our judicial judicial system
and the Attorney General's office could
there be and have you received any
feedback on that uh thank you for the
question no I haven't heard any feedback
that the point of the journey attorney
general
is you want I wanted to see this bill as
far as adoption being taught as long as
it's being taught there's no reason for
the Attorney General to get involved if
it's not there are some school districts
ignore thank you very much uh
representative Freeman thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
coming in front of us again I too share
a concern about um that Clause with the
attorney general um would you be open to
taking that particular portion out of
this bill because the rest of the bill
has an immense amount of Merit but that
I am also concerned with we don't put
that type of penalty on any other thing
in our education system right now so
would you be willing to have that um
deleted uh thank you for the question
absolutely again this bill becomes your
bill now and uh I would just hope that
the bill would go forward in one form or
another and it would
be um thank you for your testimony and
bringing forward this legislation thank
you next is representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
to the
committee I again I'm Paige boschman I
represent nashaa W 4 I am here again
today um and I would like to emphasize
um that I work per Dum at the nashaa
Department of Public Health in our
sexuality Wellness Clinic where I do STI
and STD testing and counseling all day
long so when I first saw saw this I'm
not really clear what STI and STD has to
do with
adoption um it's about STI and STDs are
about preventing infection so there are
many people coming in who aren't even
trying to get pregnant aren't thinking
about getting pregnant and
frankly many people who come in to get
STI testing are embarrassed it takes a
lot for them to get there they may not
want to go there and I understand I work
in public health but this is similar to
the kinds of clinics you would see on
college campuses so I do believe that
that is um a similar um transfer of
information and experience because
college students are young adults and
that's who I see I see kids and people
that age all the time um what I'm afraid
of is that this creates an extra barrier
or another piece um that folks in this
situation probably don't want to sit
through they want to go they want to get
their STI and STD tested they want to
get in and out they don't want to be
kept in listening to information that
they're not there to hear about and I am
afraid that that will keep people from
coming into the clinics and so this I do
believe has the potential to increase
the risk of HIV STDs STI and unintended
pregnancies because we don't have people
coming in to get that education right if
they've got an STI or an STD they need
some education around safer sex
practices and I'm really afraid that
this will decrease the number of people
coming in to get that um I do want to
add um that I uh as a healthc care guyy
nurse I'm often the first person who
will talk to a person when they call and
say I think you know I think I might be
pregnant and you learn never to say
congratulations because some people want
pregnancies and some people don't and so
the appropriate way to handle that as a
provider is that some people did not
intend to get pregnant but they're happy
about it some people did not intend to
get pregnant and they're not happy about
it and so good care is giving them all
their options we want every patient to
be fully informed before they make their
decision so I can tell you that in every
place that I've worked and even when I
had staff people are required under my
management I can't say everywhere um but
this would be best practice to give the
option of adoption anywhere that I've
had resources we have equal resources we
have abortion we have health care
providers and we have adoption resources
because that's good care oh I'm so
sorry finally I just wanted to say that
the fiscal note again is over
$100,000 I'm curious why we want to
spend that amount on education that
should be happening anyway if Healthcare
Providers are are meeting the standards
of their profession which I'd like to
assume most are
thank you very much thank you I see no
questions thank you very much again for
antel good afternoon and hello again I
would like you to support HB
730 to that extent I would like to be
know the
statistic that according to HHS there
are sadly over 1,000 children that are
in the New Hampshire state adoption
system on my page there is a
link that is 1,000 children without a
home or a family now no matter what
political party you are on whether you
are left or right I think we all want
that number to be
zero if our generation are going to be
the ones to solve this problem of Orphan
children struggling to find homes then
we need to understand the adoption
process its flaws and failings as well
as its Joys and its
successes and to make the process easier
for families who would otherwise turn to
more expensive flawed and risky
procedures like abortion or
IVF because abortion was never meant to
be used as birth control no young woman
wants to grow up and have an abortion
they dream of the day that they'll have
a family abortion always ends in a dead
baby
sorry so I I believe that teaching the
next generation is the fastest and most
sure way to get anything done and that
there is an urgent need to solve this
problem of the Thousand children without
homes and we need to learn how to deal
with this problem in a way that does not
just write many of these kids off to
abortion before they are born so help us
to have the information to be able to be
the generation where the Thousand
becomes zero and we all homeless
children have a real and loving home I
ask you to please support HB 730 God
bless you and thank you for your
time thank you very much for your
anel hi again my name is Charlotte and I
would ask you to support HB 730
I've been privileged to know many
families who have adopted children of
all ages and abilities some of them have
adopted many children with
disabilities some of them adopt children
who have fatal
diagnoses to love them for as long as
they have them because they need a place
to
be these
people these people give me
hope in a way that frankly pardon me
most of the discussion today has
not I want more than anything for our
children to recognize these people as
Heroes we need to
destigmatize adoption what people
hear about adoption usually revolves
around what's going on in the foster
care system
there's a lot of horror stories and
they're true they're absolutely
true our kids are already watching
videos about this there was a recent
release of a movie called The Sound Of
Hope the story of Pome Trot in Texas
where an entire church decided to
empty the foster care system and adopt
all of the children in spite of what
that meant for them financially
personally
through their marriages with dealing
with their own kids and all of
it and because they pulled together as a
community they gave everyone hope and
they made a video about it and it
inspired thousands of people who
attended that video is sure Charlotte if
we could stick to the bill please so I
would ask really that we give every tool
we can we that we bring in people to
talk about their experiences through the
adoption process that our children are
given what they need to be able to fix a
very broken system because there is an
urgent need these children have lives at
stake and it's not enough to say how are
we going to pay for this or what is it
that we're going to you know where are
we going to find the
time we're talking about the lives
nothing less than the lives of our
future kids and their families so we
need to give them the tools thank you
yeah and one more uh person um
representative Lorie
policy thank you thank you chairman
thank you committee um I had no plan on
talking on this bill today but um I just
felt like I should um my name is laori
coren I live in Berlin um I am a Foster
and adoptive mother um I I my husband
and I adopted our two boys um from the
foster care system um depending on the
day I would or would not recommend it
um but I am today a grandma because of
it and there's nothing better in the
world um I can say I don't want to say
how long ago I was in school
because that will tip you off on too
much information um but I remember
learning a lot of things in school I
remember learning the Pythagorean
theorem I remember learning the
quadratic
equations I remember learning that you
know if I ever got into trouble um with
an unplanned pregnancy that I could
either have the baby or abort the baby
but I was never taught about the
abortion statistics in the US I was
never taught that there's a waiting list
right now in every state in the nation
those are waiting lists of people ready
willing and just dying for the chance to
adopt a
baby I think it's a great idea to put
adoption education in our Public School
much I guess
uh that ends our testimony on House Bill
we're okay y so um as soon as our Prime
sponsor gets here we'll uh commence with
the hearing on House Bill
557 relative to the information that
thank you very much we'll open the
hearing on House Bill 557 relative to
the information that appears on the
school budget ballot and we welcome uh
co-sponsor uh representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair and members of the
education policy Administration
committee my name is Joe Alexander I
represent the town of gos toown I'm I'm
here to introduce this on behalf of my
my State Rep um representative Barry who
was unable to be here today um this bill
is pretty straightforward I think it
adds um additional context and
transparency to a school district ballot
so what would happen is um once the B
once the budget is adopted during a
deliberative session it goes to a ballot
um the new requirement under this if
this law were to pass would be to add um
a couple um contextual things to the
ballot to inform voters of what's
happening in their school district um
from my experience in gtown in
particular um we have a deliberate
session and they go really really in
depth on the budget and and there's um
strong presentations and you know voters
get a lot of detail but unfortunately
there's only about 300 voters right
right like I mean there's just people
that don't show up to these things um
which is not a good thing we should have
more involvement and I think that by
informing the the actual voters on town
meeting day
uh some of this information will be
helpful in their decision-making process
so the information that would be added
is the average cost per pupil defined by
the average daily enrollment um of the
preceded year the average daily
enrollment for the district for the
previous five years and the average
fulltime teacher to administrative
ratio um so like I said I think this is
pretty straightforward I'm not like the
you know the expert on it but I do know
that um I serve on a budget committee I
think this is pretty reasonable request
so um with that I'm happy to take
questions thank you very much uh any
questions for representative Alexander
representative babon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
I served on school boards and I've never
seen anything on a ballot that would
present this type of information a
Warren article on a ballot is specific
to the question at hand it does not
typically have any contextual
information on it as at all so I'm
wondering why you feel that this is
important to put on a ballot well I I
thank you for making my point I think
there should be contextual information
to how the school budget um is
functioning I I think there's not enough
information for voters so I think in
some ways um in gtown for instance last
year our school budget went down because
voters were um concerned about the
rising taxes but they didn't know the
context of the per people enrollment and
other things and I think if this
information is on the ballot it could
support support our local schools and
you know um help with the budget
followup please yes um most uh towns or
um communities usually send out
newsletters or put out information that
provides the context for what you would
be voting on and I know that there was a
bill last year that actually um had this
information must be presented at the
deliberative sessions so I don't see
we've already given that to the public
twice why it need to be on the ballot so
again it seems redundant and it seems
inappropriate I don't think informing
voters is inappropriate and I don't
think it's a
redundant I don't think you can be too
redundant rident Murray uh thank you Mr
ter for taking my question thank you
representative um so one of my questions
is around I think what uh representative
balbon was saying around voter guides um
packets that exist at the table when you
check in that have all of the slide
Decks that are about to be shared and
also um the school board's continual
conversation with the voting public in
their meetings throughout the academic
year that inform voters about
enrollments about changes in budgeting
um there are also budget committees that
discuss these things so I guess to that
end I am curious to know whether or
not putting this on the actual ballot
itself could potentially lead to other
confusion for the voter no thank you for
the question I don't think so I mean I
like I said I serve as chair of the
budget committee and I mean these are
conversations that come up but keep in
mind that you know the voters that want
to access this information will find the
information there are voters that go in
and vote and um you know there's I mean
in gown what do we have like 30
different things to vote on in March and
it gets to be something overwhelming for
voters so having you know where they
have to do research on 30 different
articles
um that seems to be a lot so I think by
informing voters on this specific school
budget I think is important because it
is like I said a very vital piece of the
ballot and um based on rsas it doesn't
appear right at the top it appears like
further down the ballot so this will
help inform voters and I think it I
think it's important but the voter guide
is a valuable resource and the
information that's given at delivera a
valuable resource but I don't think
there can be there can be
more follow thank you Mr chair
to that end I guess my other question is
are there any Associated cost with
potentially having to print a ballot
that would be maybe two pages or three
pages if we're continuing to put all of
this information in the um underneath
the the multiple warrants uh on the
actual ballot itself yeah that's a good
question and um you know you live in
Amherst right so um I think like my
ballots like four pages or five pages in
golf toown it really just depends I
think there there may be an added cost
right but I mean when you vote on town
meeting day they hand you like four
pieces of paper and you're just like
please flip it over flip it overlip it's
like it's a lot but I think it's a cost
that obviously there's not a fiscal note
on it so I don't think that anybody
thinks it's a significant
cost represent Hall thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question can
you speak to how this affects sb2
districts well I I anticipate that this
I guess I'm not the election law expert
on this I think I'm just referring to
what's happening in our small our SP2
towns um so I can't speak to like the
cities in particular if that's what
you're referring to okay thank you
because if if they have a traditional
town
meeting there wouldn't be a ballot and
they would provide the information at
the town
meeting does that make does that answer
well okay Corell thank you thank you for
taking my um my question is about lines
11 through 13 um the average full-time
teacher to administrator ratio I don't
know if you know we have a bill before
us about part-time teachers who would
teach under 20 hours so I don't know how
that would affect this because we could
have a lot of the part-time teachers who
would be there to teach different
classes and also administrator means all
other full time positions what do you
what would be included under
that
so full so the question the first
question about part-time teachers I
believe that school districts measure
this on um part-time or or equivalencies
to full-time positions so that's how I
would read the law is like if it's a
part-time it's like a point4 of a
teacher or 0 five of a teacher depending
on how many hours they spend at
instruction so that's how IID read the
the law on the first one and regardless
to administrators it says means all
other full-time positions I think we're
talking about um positions like special
ed coordinator um yeah but that aren't
that aren't primarily associated with
educating our children in in in an
educational space follow up follow
that's not clear to me though because it
says all other full-time positions could
it mean the custodians could it mean the
nurse could it mean the guidance
counselor um
cafeteria workers oh I mean that's a
great question I don't think that
anybody's uh um trying to lead people on
and saying like custodians are
administrators so if there's something
that you would like to clear up the
language I'm sure the sponsor would be
grateful for but um I I don't think that
we're it's fulltime trying to imply that
custodians are administrators and I
don't think anybody would think that but
but but it follow up follow but somebody
could interpret it that way guess so
yeah thank you Sky could be light blue
today as opposed to dark blue uh further
further questions seen none thank you
very much representative
Christina thank you chairman cordelli
thank you members of uh the committee uh
my name is bar R executive director of
the New Hampshire school Association we
are opposed to House Bill 557 I do
appreciate representative Alexander's um
testimony knowing he was filling in for
for representative Barry um I'd like to
point the committee to RSA 189 col
76 uh passed out of this committee well
the former hous head Committee just last
year July 1st effective date July 1st
20025 mandatory report to voters before
any meeting at which any school dist
adopts a school budget whether or not
the school district has adopted the
provisions of RSA 194
c9b a mandatory report to voters shall
be posted in three appropriate places
two of which must be places of business
and other public locations posted seven
days prior to the meeting the first line
of the graph shall be titled average
cost per pupil the second line of the
graph shall be titled average teacher
salary the third line of the graph shall
be titled administrative salaries the
table shall be titled top administrator
salaries the information that would be
posted on the ballot is already required
to be posted on the school district
website per action of this body not even
a year ago uh the second aspect that we
have um representative Cornell we had
the same question about um administrator
means all other full-time positions all
other full-time positions could be
custodians a school nurse um I don't
know pair professionals are are working
full-time or your food service workers
are full working full-time but perhaps
speech therapists um and any number of
of full-time positions in in any number
of school districts across the state um
again um this information is also posted
on the Department of Education website
if anybody wants to see the average cost
per pupil the Department of Education
has been um uh actively um advocating
awareness of I believe it's called the I
platform um the school boards
Association has done webinars um with
the Department to bring that to light to
our school board members um and pres
will be out to the community alarm just
to how to find whatever data and
information that you want to find about
your particular School District um
further uh we know that the school
district is required to have a budget
hearing under RSA 32 um prior to annual
meetings and prior to the budget being
presented some communities have budget
committees um where the budget committee
is hosting the um uh the budget hearing
we have deliberative sessions uh where
voters can ask questions so there's
certainly other Public public uh public
opportunities for V voters ask questions
um about average teacher salary number
of Staff number of Administrators so on
and so forth um and last um I just as
always when we get bills like this why
just school districts um if it's good
for school districts and transparency is
the goal to make voters more informed um
this should apply to towns cities
Village districts and maybe the state
budget maybe we can require some of
these things to be put into house bill
too about the number of state employees
and the number of salaries for agency
heads and so on and so forth so uh with
that the school boards Association
opposes House Bill 557 and I'm happy
happy to answer any
questions uh thank you represent of
selling C can you just um at the
beginning you gave us a specific um bill
number could you say that again but
slowly please yes so RSA 189 colon 76 I
forget the bill number from last year
but that that law became effective July
2025 thank you very much so I guess it's
not effective now I just my mistake I
just realized we delayed that a year but
but anyway it it it it would be required
moving forward thank you I just couldn't
write as fast as you spoke if you could
the effective date again yeah I'm sorry
thank you I I may have misspoke earlier
representative cordelli the effective
date is July 1
2025 so let's say this this bill did
become law they would becoming law
concurrently anyway because this
certainly is not going to be on the
ballot in in another six weeks or
whatever at your at your annual meeting
so representative Freeman
thank you Mr chair and thank you um for
coming in front of us so would you not
agree that this is very different than
posting the information as opposed to
printing it on a ballot it's think of
the question representative sure it's
certainly different than posting it on
the website than having it on the ballot
in front of the voters as they're voting
but my point is that the information is
already being required to be distributed
to the voters in the community at large
anyway via the website and via the
ability of people to ask questions at
the budget hearing um and not even just
the budget hearing the budget committee
meetings are supposed to be posted
anyway so there's ample opportunity for
the public to attend budget meeting
budget committee meetings um school
board meetings and the deliberative
session to ask these questions without
it having to be printed on the
ballot thank you I see no further
questions uh except for representative s
sorry my kicking in slowly um would
School boards uh school yeah uh saus
print their ballots for their to the
School elections um would this add extra
cost do you believe thank you for the
question uh representative I mean I I
really don't know I did hear
representative uh Alexander's comments
let's say it was an extra page and let's
say the average ballot is four pages
long you know and I don't know how many
ballots are usually printed up in a town
representative Alexander from GF town I
believe so let's say a thousand so 10
cent a page times another thousand maybe
an extra $100 so presumably there could
be but I mean without looking through
you know all the ballots and all the
communities it hard for me to ascertain
that thank
you now I think we're done all right
thank you thank you very
much
uh oh I'm
sorry I'm trying I'm
trying I just got the gavel so I'm I
guess I'm trying to uh use it uh
watching um that's wonderful Mr chair so
uh represent
representative Jerry FW thank you thank
you Mr chair uh I'm not going Jerry FW
Associated exe executive director of New
Hampshire school administrators
Association I'm not going to repeat the
points that uh Mr Christina has made uh
but we did there were some questions
that um were raised in in my mind in
looking at this bill first we agree
transparency voter education
understanding school school budgets
absolutely essential we wish more people
would take the time to actually become
more educated about school budgets and
attend those school board meetings when
they're presented and listen and hear
the dialogue understand the
justification and rationale for things
so we are not we are all about
transparency and support and
understanding of school district budgets
some of the questions that came to mind
in reading this
um reading this bill um on line six
section two immediately proceeding the
question um the following information
shall be presented one of the questions
that came to mind is one other committee
somewhere here in this building has
talked about electioneering and I don't
know what the interface of
electioneering and putting information
detailed information on a ballot would
be what that interface would be I just
don't know I'm I'm not a smart guy just
it's one of those things that causes me
to wonder could there be a potential
legal issue if you had detailed
information on a ballot as opposed to
another set of information and and I I
would cite that when I was the
superintendent at kirar um we had a
deliberate session and all of the
detailed information was handed out at
the deliberative session everything was
there that people needed to know to
support ask questions query the
administration on who makes what who
does what it was all in a separate piece
my question is if that information
becomes part of the ballot does that
constitute electioneering or does it
constitute a potential if something's
Miss stated does it constitute a legal
challenge that then the school district
has to incur in defending the B I don't
know
um Barrett talked about the bills last
year um same question as raised by I
believe representative Cornell if uh
what what classifies as an
administrative position I I don't know
uh what that would be as a
superintendent um and trying to build a
budget I would probably in all honesty
try to include anything that could be
construed as an administrative position
but does that need definition the IT
director the special ed director the
facilities director are the the
principal the assistant principal um in
the in the schools what are
administrative positions I think that
needs
clarification
um
and the part-time question um if in fact
part time uh full-time positions are
being measured to the question of how
does part-time
apply a suggestion could be made that
full-time
equivalence would be a more appropriate
um wording of this because there are
especially in some of our small rural
districts there are a number of
part-time positions all added up you
know a million here A Millionaire it all
counts for something but if you have a
halftime music and a halftime art that
wouldn't NE necessarily factor into this
language so if is if you're really
looking at the um full-time equivalence
of of that's more transparent in terms
of what you're hiring and have on hand
for Staffing um providing instruction
and that's all thank you very much any
questions representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in front of us so would you
not agree that um as of late most
deliberative sessions aren't very well
attended seeing as you were the
superintendent kage I'm sure you've seen
deliberative sessions
before thank you for the question
representative Freeman and and I would
respectfully disagree that especially
citing kage I think their session was
pretty well attended most recently so um
and it would be my experience and and
again I can speak to mine I haven't been
at other places when I was in sau6 the
Brentwood uh School District meeting
Full House you know had to have lots of
chairs in the gym people standing around
so people participate in in governance
when given the opportunity thank you
thank you representative Murray thank
you Mr chair um and thank you for taking
my question wouldn't you also agree that
do um in addition to in-person
attendance there's also another modality
that folks can watch things virtually um
and can be informed that way as
well thank you for the question
representative Mary I do believe that
there are plenty of opportunities for
people to observe through uh televised
school board meetings through televised
deliberative sessions and televised
meetings or or um otherwise projected
those who want to procure information
can thank you uh representative
Bon thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um something you
brought up kind of strike struck me as
another potential issue with the um
positions is I my uh district is part of
an SAU and there are also Co-op
situations where we share and
administrators and in terms of figuring
that out I mean how do I figure it out
like Ry has a certain percent you can't
really spell out how much time an
Administration is spending on my town Ry
or opposed to what's Greenland or
Newington or Newcastle I mean I don't I
have no idea how you would Define that
do you see also see that an issue with
co-ops thank you for the question uh I
would submit uh representative bbon that
yes there there's an some consideration
again I defer back to the experience in
sau6 um various central office people
had various responsibilities in the
smaller communities in the smaller towns
as well as responsibilities to the ler
Co-op and SST uh and the SAU as as an
umbrella as a body and I I also um one
of the questions actually that just came
to mind is in responding to
representative Bon's question is where
did contracted service providers uh fit
into the full-time part-time staff um
right because you if and I think about
special education a lot of special
education um service providers right now
are contracted services so how does that
if you trying to be transparent to the
taxpayer about where the money's going
then how do the how do the contracted
Bill thank you see no further questions
um I thinkk you oh I'm sorry here thank
you for taking my question are seus
unhappy with what they do right now
generally speaking you know the whole
part do they need
this no we're happy bunch of
people thank
you thank you very much representative
selig thank you and thank you for taking
my question so I know that my school
district o River we have our own Fleet
of buses and our own internal bus
drivers but I know that that's not
common across the state do you have a
sense of how many districts subcontract
out two external bus companies versus
having an internal one and how that
would factor into this and they would be
thank you for the question
representative S I do not have the
information in terms of who are their
self um transportation providers versus
who trans uh who contracts with others
but once again there's a full-time
part-time service component if you will
of personnel that's providing service to
kids and families there yeah thank you
very much and uh thank you for your
testimony and with that
we'll close uh House Bill
557 um and uh that ends our morning and
we'll resume at uh 1 pm with House Bill
you
e
have copies of the next bill 394 several
of us do not I just wondering how many
need okay one
put
this1
to
e
copies of our first bill uh for the
afternoon which is House Bill
394 and it's relative to the powers and
duties of Cooperative School District
budget committees and the role of
Cooperative School District Board member
Representatives on such
committees and um our Prime sponsor is
here welcome uh to this education
committee this is becoming a very
familiar room for me thank you for
having me um those of you who were on
the education committee last term uh
heard from me when I presented two bills
and those two bills uh relating to
Cooperative School District budget
committees were both ultimately referred
to interim
study and in the interim Study
deliberations last fall um they were
recommended for further legislation and
in the
discussion I uh concurred with the
suggestion that they be merged into one
bill so 394 will look familiar to some
of
you HB
394 has two distinct purposes
they're severable but they fit into the
general question of what we're asking
our Cooperative School District budget
committee to do for us and so I think
it's appropriate to have them in one
bill speaking to them one at a
time what the bill does in line 15 14
and
15 is it simply says that the school
boards ex officio members sitting with
the budget committee
will not have a
vote and uh so why why why do I think
that this bill is
necessary first of all the purpose of
the budget committee is to provide
expertise to provide
focus and uh to provide some form of
check and balance in terms of creating
the budget with the administration and
the school
board and the statutes say that a budget
committee will be comprised it will be
composed exactly in the same manner as
the as the school
board so taking uh I represent
Charlestown Newport Unity Charlestown is
a member of the Fall Mountain uh
Regional School District it's one of
five
towns and uh there's a delicate balances
I think there is in most of these
districts it's a seven uh seat school
board with five prior districts and each
of those towns has one dedicated uh
board seat and then there are two at
large so naturally you would expect from
the statute that the budget committee
would also have seven members five from
each of the towns and two at large but
lo and behold we now take one member of
the school board and add them in and
give them a vote and the result is a
little weird so
it means that the balance of the seven
each Town having a representative and
the voters at large deciding the other
two is thrown off it means that instead
of the statutory designed to have an odd
number of votes we end up with an eighth
vote and an even one and we have
situations where that results in very
ambiguous outcomes and
guidance and uh it means that we have
given one individual ual uh extra power
to have a vote on both boards I
coincidentally the Fall Mountain
deliberative session is this evening
I've spent a fair bit of time looking at
the warrant and uh there are quite a few
of the
warrants that uh involve a different
vote from the school board and from the
budget committee and there are some
where the budget committee is saying no
and the school board is saying yes where
the budget committee is saying one
figure and the school board is saying
another the whole purpose of having the
budget committee is to provide the
voters with more information and as I
said before expertise focus and checks
and
balances this is just a very very weird
thing where you look in one part of Law
and it says composed exactly alike then
you look at this and it throws it off so
please I have no quibble with the role
of an ex
officio I think that ex officio brings a
perspective acts as a liazon facilitates
communication that's all good but it
doesn't require that person have a
vote the second part of the bill in uh
the additional
language added to uh subsection
2 uh in lines 22 to
29 is basically going to one point right
now our statute uh 19 512a is very clear
that the annual budget must be referred
to the budget
committee and it's not so clear that the
budget committee should have the same
sort of role in any other off-budget
cycle uh new
spending I'm not talking about decisions
to spend what's already been
appropriated I'm talking about those uh
instances in the year supplemental
Appropriations some sort of an emergency
hearing uh or in fact the question that
arises every two years with the state
aid I'll explain that in a moment um
every one of those
cases should equally have the budget
committee's attention and the voters
should have the budget committee's
evaluation and
opinion
so here we are in a budget year and what
occurred two years ago uh in the Fall
Mountain district is that the district's
budget was set by the voters in
March the uh State's budget was set in
June by the legislature and signed by
the governor and it included uh
increased adequacy Aid so the increased
adequacy Aid is uh is defined and and
approved and given a number after the
school's budget has been uh approved and
the school board treated that in October
as a
windfall they bypassed the budget
committee and called a quick hearing to
propose that about
$280,000 be spent on Paving and parking
lots and uh second uh entrance or egress
to the high school now whether that's a
good thing or not is ultimately up to
the voters but again the voters are
supposed to be informed not just by the
school board's opinion but also the
budget committee's opinion the purpose
of this language is just to
ensure that when new Appropriations are
asked
for they have to go to the budget
committee and that was never meant to be
confined Strictly To The Once annual
budget okay um so I hope that explains
the bill well I I think they're pretty
self-explanatory and obvious I I
certainly see very clear instances in my
own district and Community where these
two things make a difference and I
imagine that uh many of you will
probably also relate in terms of what
you've seen in your own districts glad
to take any questions thank you uh
representative
Woodcock thank you thank you take my
question I appreciate the clarity of
your testimony thank you can you go back
to the second part of the expenditure
the the windfall yes and run it through
to us had this been in
place right so had it been in place the
school board would have referred this
matter to the budget committee the
budget committee could have met quickly
and given their opinion before the
public hearing was held and so when this
public hearing was
called we have Five Towns um I think
that's probably close to 8 or 10,000
voters uh 2600 or so in my town and uh I
was offered the uh call upon for the
first question and my question is where
does the budget committee stand on this
and they said oh we haven't referred it
to the budget committee I said and why
is that and we got a legal opinion from
The District's attorney who was sitting
there say well the statute doesn't
explicitly state that anything beyond
the annual budget has to go to the
budget committee and I I said right then
and there well I think a bill needs to
be introduced to make that
clear want to follow up Mr chair yes so
going back to the windfall under the
this provision had it been there so the
the school board would have said say yes
the budget committee would have said say
no and then it goes to the voters just
of those recommendations or to stop by
the budget committee I'm not familiar
with the Cooperative School process all
right no the budget committee s simply
gives an opinion they have no ability to
approve or disapprove okay thank you
thank you Mr chair sure represent Sul
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question I'm looking um at
lines 26
Etc um where it says no warrant article
shall be printed on the annual town
meeting ballot or special meeting ballot
without the approval of the committee
and I'm curious if there's an item for
example in my district they just
approved a new teacher contract um after
protracted negotiations which at our um
deliberative session the voters approved
to go on to the ballot without Amendment
um but so in this case if the budget
Committee disapproved of that negotiated
contract that would that then hold it
from being able to go
because you just said that it was just
advisory it wasn't no I think you're
asking a very good question I'm trying
to understand how that's G to play
together so I I'd like to think this
through carefully read this carefully
perhaps an amendment would address what
you're asking so let me just clarify
what the intent is the intent is not
that the budget committee could prevent
it from going to the voters but rather
that the um it would be referred to the
voters with the vote not just of the
school board but also at the budget
committee and and if we we can clarify
that that would be great ask
clarification thank you so much so you
would say amending it to say that um the
warrant article shouldn't be printed on
the on on the ballot uh without the
information from the committee or the
opinion of the committee correct for
example corre yes yes something very
much along the lines of what you said
okay ref Murray thank you Mr CH thank
you representative for taking my
question in the same sort of uh same
area same conversation I'm trying to
think about what would happen in the
event of are you asking for like the
dispositive vote by the budget committee
to recommend
approval ex you know I'm not I'm not in
any way requiring an approval and I
think this goes to representative cel's
question um what I'm what I would like
this to require is that it be referred
to the budget committee budget committee
has an opportunity to assess it to take
a vote and to have that vote recorded so
that the voters are informed of where
the budget committee stands is very
important not
just um you know to have a majority but
it's also very important for the voters
to know when something is Unified or
whether it's divided so it may be 43 in
favor but I still think it's an
important bit of knowledge that it was
not
yes follow up if I may um and maybe this
was dealt with an election law at one
point but I do recall there
being conversation around uh in the
following lines 28 and 29 where it does
say that the vote of the prop uh on each
proposal shall be recorded and printed
on the
ballot is that in statute anywhere
already it's not in Statute in regards
to Cooperative School District budget
committees
further
questions you sure I am okay so thank
you I'm just thinking back to the
previous Bill where we had a qu question
about electioneering based on
information printed on a ballot and I
don't know whether this would raise the
same legal question I don't know if
that's a question for you or for the for
the sponsor or from an attorney um but
just where that was a question that came
up earlier today about could such
information be construed as
electioneering um I just don't know if
there's a legal
opinion my personal opinion is it would
not be electioneering just to have the
vote of the any committee but um but I
am also not a lawyer um I I would like
to weigh in but without the benefit of
having heard what you were discussing
earlier
uh I don't I can't say whether this is a
uniform practice across the state but
it's certainly a long-standing and
uniform practice in the Fall Mountain
School District that the warrant article
does
disclose uh the school board's a vote on
every warrant including the requisitions
from uh uh um Capital reserves and and
various other issues uh Fall Mountain
District only voted in March
22 uh to establish a budget committee
under
195 and uh so this is only the third
budget C but the budget committee's vote
is recorded in the warrant uh um for the
budget for the school teachers or staff
contracts etc etc it's it's just these
what I'm aiming at here is these events
that
occur between the annual January
February March cycle of budget hearing
representative
Boni thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question again I'm not
familiar with the Cooperative District
process um I belong to an SIU so it's a
little bit different so what I hear
you're saying is you already have the
authority to do this during the um
annual budget process and what this bill
is attempting to do is to allow it to
occur for
um potential funds that might come up
during the year and those purposes but
two questions um is there a limit or a
lower threshold of you know expenditures
where you see that it's important for
the budget committee to weigh in on and
also um again procedure wise in a public
hearing it says having a ballot um
that's different for me too I don't
understand why you would have a ballot
hearing no you don't have a ballot
taking your second question first you
don't have a ballot in the public
hearing you have a public hearing before
it goes to the
voters so I'm sorry follow so mid year
you would have like another vote a
townwide vote I think the mechanics can
vary and how that vote is taken I don't
know but all this is trying to get at is
that the budget committee opines before
the decision is
made I'm sorry what was your first
oh the first question was on the um a
lower limit of you know you're talking
about Capital expenditures there's no um
I mean it could be anything I mean you
don't have a lower what what amount of
what you would be asking to weigh in on
right that's true the bill doesn't have
a lower um yeah and and frankly if the
committee thought that there was some
threshold over which this was meaningful
um I would have no objection to that but
I would think that threshold would be
very low
100 repres
Murray thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question with regard to
lines 24 through
20 it's like six and a halfish with
regard to the expenditures and a public
hearing until the budget committee has
had an opportunity for review and
evaluation how do non-public sessions
that are talking about all sorts of
things that might have an expenditure to
them um through various types of
negotiation be impacted by this
requirements I don't think they'd be
impacted at all I mean the 195 elsewhere
I don't have the citation off my uh top
of my head is very clear in saying that
the kind of appropriation that I
described uh that comes after the
legislative budget is set and generally
in the fall um takes a while for those
figures even to be calculated and
disseminated out to the district very
clearly requires a hearing but the
question of the hearing is what's the
value of the hearing if the budget
committee hasn't had a chance to
evaluate it and present their opinion
the purpose of the hearing is to inform
the voting public and to allow them to
ask questions so that's the exact
juncture that we were at in October uh
bill for the questions see none uh thank
you representative thank you very
Christina thank you again chairman
cordelli uh good afternoon members of
the committee bar Christina from the
school boards Association I do want to
thank representative spillsbury for
having some conversations with nhba
relative to this I think there are some
areas where we might be able to reach
some agreement um I certainly understand
representative's position the
representative spilsbury's position and
explanation of some of these um some of
his concerns and and and what the bill
says some we might agree with and some
some we might we might disagree with um
I'm going to start with the first
section that removes um the school board
member from having a a voting um a a
voting right um on on the budget
committee I understand Representatives
representative spilsbury's position that
that individual is voed twice once for
the school board and then once on the
budget committee um but I suppose um
rather and and the concerns about it
being an even numbered body and
potentially for a tie vote a couple
points on that one rather than um having
rather than eliminating the school board
members vote on the budget committee um
I suppose because could just amend the
statute and add an extra member of the
budget committee another at large
position so you would have an odd number
of people um still having the vote um
two um uh this body may be aware that
from time to time public bodies um come
out with ti votes and then it goes to
the larger body without a recommendation
we may have seen that a couple of times
in this in this building over the last
couple of years so that might that might
be one option it goes on the the the the
budget or the whatever the the warrant
article is goes on the ballot or goes to
the annual meeting without a
recommendation from the uh from the
budget committee um and I guess the the
third aspect to that is um nothing that
you can really put in statute but if
there is continued disagreement among
the budget committee as to whether or
not to support or whether or not to
oppose the budget in my opinion the
School Board needs to perhaps do a
better job explaining the budget and
maybe there needs to be some better
communication between the bucom and the
School Board as to why the bucom wants
to cut or the school board wants to add
but I understand we can't legislate that
but I just wanted to throw that out
there that you know if we're having TI
votes all the time or or there's
disagreement then perhaps the deeper
conversations need to be had among the
the bodies um at at issue um relative to
a couple of the other things um in the
bill um and that that that
representative spillsbury mentioned um
there may need to be my my my concern
con ER with some of with changing some
of the provisions in The Cooperative
School District statute and
1952a I believe we're we're talking
about is that I think there are some
Provisions in RSA 32 the municipal
budget statute that speak to budgets and
budget committees and and
recommendations on warrant articles that
that may need to be changed to Encompass
all budget committees and not
necessarily just Cooperative School
District budget committees for example
if we look at existing language I'm on
the I guess the bill is only one page so
the first page of the bill lines 19
through 21 such Cooperative School Board
Cooperative school budget committee
shall have all the powers in duties of
the municipal budget committee under the
provisions of RSA 32 in so far as the
budget for the Cooperative school
district is concerned and in so far as
RSA 32 is applicable to Cooperative
school boards so one point of of uh to
to raise I I believe there was a
question about the notation of the
budget committee whether or not they
recommend the warrant article or don't
recommend the warrant article this is
RSA 32 colon 5 and again RSA 32 the
municipal budget statute RSA 32 colon 5
paragraph 5 when any purpose of
appropriation submitted by a governing
body the school board or by petition
appears in the warrant as part of a
special warrant article the article
shall contain a notation of whether or
not that appropriation is recommended by
the governing body and if there is a
budget committee a notation of whether
or not it is recommended by by the
budget committee so if we've got a
warrant article that calls for an
appropriation and you have a budget
committee that budget committee is
supposed to to give their thumbs up or
thumbs down and that is not notated on
on the warrant further along um uh I'm
on page I guess I'm still on lines 22
and 23 Additionally the committee shall
review and evaluate any proposed warrant
articles or supplemental Appropriations
involving the expenditure of funds I
believe representative spillsbury said
that current law says that the bucom is
only responsible for overseeing the
general overall operating budget as I
read through the statute this is RSA
32 colon 16 um the budget committee is
responsible for one to prepare the
budget as provided in RSA 32 col 5 and
if authorized under the sb2 statute a
default budget um I think nhba can get
behind the notion that if a warrant
article is calling for an appropriation
whether or not it's the the the general
overall operating budget or it's a
separate warrant article $50,000 for the
playground um if the bucom wants to
weigh in on that I I think I think
that's completely reasonable again that
might need to go in RSA 32 co15 though
and not necessarily in The Cooperative
statute the the one um area where nhba
would disagree with the the the the bill
uh the last aspect of line 23 and on 24
including withdrawals from capital
reserve funds not previously authorized
um we would disagree with the budget
committee necessarily having a say over
the withdrawal from the capital reserve
fund the money that is put into a
capital reserve fund has already been
appropriated by the voters whether or
not that money has been raised by taxes
or often times looking back to your own
districts you'll probably see that year-
end Surplus is is put into a a capital
reserve fund and that may be not not a
capital reserve fund but any reserve
fund that may be a capital reserve fund
it may for special education purposes
you know if there's year on Surplus
we're going to throw $100,000 into the
special education trust fund or the
special education trust fund so to build
that up in case we get a high cost kid
that moves in so that money has already
been appropriated by the voters the
voters have already authorized that
money to go into that trust fund the way
that operates now with the how that is
expended is
RSA 35 colon 15 this is the the statute
capital reserve funds for of counties
towns districts and water departments
persons holding set capital reserve
funds and Trust as provided in this
chapter shall hold the same until such
time as the town District or County
shall have voted to withdraw funds from
from such capital reserve fund or shall
have named the named agents of the Town
District or County to carry out the
objects designated by the town District
or county in a manner prescribed by RSA
35 col 3 now in many cases if a school
district has a reserve fund the school
board is named the agent of that trust
fund is
authorized um by the voters to be clear
authorized by the voters to be the ones
to expend that that that trust fund
so if we have
$250,000 in a special education trust
fund and midyear that budget looks like
it's going to get blown for whatever
reasons we don't have to hold special
hearings the school board doesn't
necessarily have to go back to the
voters um doesn't have to go to the
budget committee because the voters have
already authorized the school board to
be the agent to expend that money so we
would disagree with the language um in
the in the in the bill um about
including withdrawals from capital
reserve funds we think again RSA 35
already authorizes whoever the agent is
to be able to do that
um uh continuing on uh no such
expenditure may be the subject may be
the subject of a notice hearing or
meeting of the legislative body until
the budget committee has had an
opportunity to review and evaluate um
review and evaluate be mindful of that
language because I'm looking at
representative spillsbury talked about
um the Fall Mountain School District
received some extra excess adequacy Aid
this year there's a statute RSA 197
3-a special meetings for changes in
education funding we put this Statute in
I want to say in 2011 or so um when
there were some changes to the adequacy
formula and districts were getting more
money they had already had annual
meetings we weren't sure what the law
was at the time we meeting sort of the
collective
educational uh uh uh uh uh Community if
you will in New Hampshire about whether
or not we could accept that money
whether or not we had to have a special
a special meeting to accept the extra
money so this States again
3-a it says in response to statutory
changes resting resulting in reductions
or increases in distribution of State
revenues for Education pursuing to RSA
198 col 41 to school districts which
would take effect after the adoption of
the new School District budget after
annual meeting
and would apply in the fiscal year
covered by the new budget the governing
body of a school district May after
consultation with the budget committee
call a special meeting of the
legislative body to consider a reduction
recision increase of Appropriations made
at the annual meeting so in that
circumstance the budget committee has to
be I guess just notified but the budget
committee does not um have a vote or a
say or make a recommendation whether or
not that excess adequacy Aid or or what
to to do with it give it back to the
taxpayers put up a new roof put in an
HVAC system whatever the case may be so
um you know again there may be there may
be a change in in a different statute
beyond what is being presented today um
if if if there's excess you know nhsp
doesn't have an opinion on whether or
not that excess a should go to the bucom
for a vote um I I guess just without
thinking it through I think we'd be
pretty neutral on that um but
um the other aspect with I'll skip that
um anyway so I I think that's going to
wrap up wrap up my my testimony um you
know some of the some some of the things
again nsba can certainly get behind um
you know if there's any appropriation
that or if there's any warrant article
that calls for an appropriation Beyond
just the budget if the bucom wants to
review that make a recommendation I
don't think nsba would have a specific
objection to that but I think that's
more an RSA
32 um uh issue the municipal budget um
law rather than a Cooperative School
District so um representative spillsbury
and I have had some some conversations
um if you want to work together sir we
can we can certainly try and do that um
so um I think I think that's my
testimony and I hope I was clear I know
we've got sort of a shotgun approach
with a bunch of statutes that are being
impacted here but I think more of these
again relate to sort of the overall
budgeting process rather than are
necessarily specific to Cooperative
school districts and with that I will
try to answer any questions but I give
you no
guarantees thank you thank you uh
representative Murray why don't you give
give it a
try thank you Mr chair um I I do have a
question with and I just want to make
sure I'm understanding your comment with
regard to 197 uh 3A yeah it is my
recollection in past in in various you
know
um in the in the towns that I represent
um there have been circumstances where
special meetings were called and it was
the am I understanding correctly it is
the vote of the body present to decide
whether or not to return those funds
back to the taxpayers uh thank you for
the question representative yes I
believe it is I the school board so I
um special meeting the governing the
governing this is RSA 197
3-a paragraph 3 the governing B's
warrant shall specify in one or more
articles the amounts of Appropriations
proposed for reduction recision or
increase from the operating budget or
separate more articles or both adopted
at the annual
meeting
um so if the school board wants to
expend that money they need to have a
purpose for whether or not it's just
added to your general budget um you know
or or or presumably this I think the I
think the governing body I think the
school board has the if the voters
authorize the appropriation I think the
governing body has Authority on how it's
going to be expended whether or not
that's again included in your general
operating budget for cost that you know
maybe on unanticipated cost or the or
the governing body certainly has the
authority to return it to the taxpayers
at the end of the year to reduce taxes
for the following year I believe that
power rest with the governing body
though represent s thank you very quick
question um I wasn't entirely clear
whether you objected to the school board
member who's sitting on the budget
committee having being there without the
ability to vote I I couldn't quite
decide yeah certainly so I I I I mean
representing School boards I'm going to
say that individual should have a vote I
certainly I certainly understand
representative spilsbury's rationale for
for for the changes in the in the bill
yeah president Murray thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question my
other question is with regard to that as
well are there other circumstances where
other types of EX official members sit
on school boards that are you know not
within a budget committee or not within
a I
think don't quote me on this I think
there may be somewhere in statute or
rules where the superintendent is deemed
an ex official member that may be in
Department of Education
rules and if I can find it in the
interum and I catch you during a break
or something I I can clarify that but in
terms of statutory
nothing nothing is coming to mind in
terms of in terms of Statute
representative thank you yeah thank
you would you have any idea how many
Cooperative uh districts have a budget
committee thank you for the question I
don't know that representa we know that
there are 32 co-ops across the state um
I don't know if the Dr has that or or
just it's not something that we've trct
curious yeah
yeah see no further questions thank you
much was there yes representative
spilsbury yes return trip to the uh
witness
chair thank you uh I'm not coming back
to rut and and and turn and turn this
into a debate but just simply to clarify
two things uh number one I would
encourage you on in regard to the uh ex
officio voting or non- voting capacity
not to further distort or complicate the
bill by adding yet another member which
takes it further away from being
balanced in the same fashion as a school
board so I would suggest that you do
what the bill proposes uh regarding the
uh the budget committee's role I think
the reference to RSA 32 is important and
I having been on the town's finance
committee I understand RSA 32 very well
and there's a lot of complication
between the way 195 interrelates but I
think the problem is introduced right
here in the text of 1952a if you look at
the existing statutory language in lines
19 to
21 says such Cooperative school budget
committee shall have the powers and
duties of the municipal budget committee
under the provisions of RSA 32 it
doesn't stop there with a
period it then says in so far as the
budget for the Cooperative school
district is concerned and that's
precisely the language that the attorney
for the school district pointed to in
arguing that uh nothing outside of the
budget should be referred to the budget
committee so I'll just leave it at that
I think that the statute is in fact
problematic it needs a solution and I
would be very happy to work with Mr
Christina to offer you some language
that address the questions I think good
thank you for that
um see no further questions thank you
and um yeah we look forward to uh to
getting a resolution for this is you
know this is really held over from uh
last term so uh I I think there is uh is
this and our
next hearing is about a minute
away
uh yeah right sticking in one BS in the
peek or something so I remember yeah
maybe I can find a flag sticker or
for
e
is not a new bill to the house in fact
it's been introduced to the house
before as House Bill 56
3 very close in number that was a couple
of years ago the same concept was
introduced in the senate in Senate Bill
155 it was passed by the Senate but
later uh killed by the
house what this bill does is it requires
that the SAU budget be separated from
the School District
budget and placed on the ballot
so that the voters can vote separately
on the SAU
budget why is this a good
idea frequently such as in my town of
eping
sau14 the administrative costs of
running the SAU are buried in the School
District budget and it's virtually
impossible for the average person to dig
through that budget and find the line
SAU it would be extremely helpful to the
voters for transparency purposes to be
able to say okay this is an
administrative cost versus this cost
students now I know the role of the SAU
is to provide services for the education
of our students administrative
services but increasingly over the last
10 years those Services have grown to
include more than just Educational
Services and it would be useful for
voters to be able to see that and make a
decision for themselves about whether
they wanted those services or not after
all it's the voters money taxpayers
money they ought to be able to to choose
money so this
legislation will give voters that
opportunity now I know that last year
the house passed and the governor signed
into law a provision that says that SAU
budgets do have to be broken out
separately and displayed prominently on
the SAU
website but that law doesn't take effect
until July 1st of
2024 uh 2025 rather so those of us who
are trying to make sense of our current
school budget still don't have the
opportunity to see the separate SAU
costs in addition the law passed last
year while it
requires the breakout of the
administrative cost and the display of
those costs on the SAU website it
doesn't allow the voters to vote
separately on that SAU
budget hence the need for House Bill
564 to allow the voters the opportunity
budget now because I'm suggesting that
voters deserve this
opportunity to vote separately on the
SAU budget doesn't mean that I believe
that saus are not spending money wisely
or that they are uh providing services
that people don't
want I'm not suggesting that at all the
SAU in my town SAU 14 I think does a
great job uh I know several of the
people who work in the SAU office and I
uh interact with them frequently they're
all good people working hard and and
doing a good
job nevertheless I still think voters
ought to have a
choice are there some administrative
services that we want that we're not
getting are there some administrative
services that we are getting that maybe
we don't want voters should have that
choice I
believe so that's why I've introduced
House Bill
564 hopefully third time times a charm
and maybe uh this time this proposal
will will be able to to move
forward I'm not going to talk too much
more about that I think I've laid out
the case for this bill uh I'd be happy
to answer questions but I will
preface that by saying that I am no e
expert on
education uh the education statutes I'll
do the best I J best I can to answer
questions but uh if I come up short it's
because I'm more of an expert about
energy than I am about
education so thank you and happy to
answer questions thank you uh
representative U
Lichfield thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my
question first thank you so much for
bringing this forward um this has been
actually a complaint that I've heard
many times in our district you don't
have a say on the SAU budget my question
is could we get um the reader digest
version of why HP
563 did not pass the house and why
Senate Bill 155 was killed in the house
that I was not involved with either of
those bills so I'm not entirely
certain I was it was explained to me
that in one of those two bills and I
don't remember which one there was some
difficulty about how to handle saus that
had more than one school district in
them so this bill addresses that issue
it clearly describes a process for um
dealing with multi-district saus versus
single District saus it's spelled out in
the language of the bill I hope that
answered the
question representative
SEL thank you um and thank you for
taking my question and it may be that
it's a question that Mr Christina is
more able to answer but wouldn't the
voters be able by attending budget
hearings budget information sessions the
um deliberative session and so on be
able to know and ask question not at the
deliberative session but at the previous
budget hearings and whatnot be able to
ask all of the questions and get the
information so that should they wish to
make an amendment to the budget they
could do that at their deliberative
sessions already isn't that the way
their system already
Works yes I'm sure that voters could do
that the problem is very few voters
choose to do that
and there ought to be a way that voters
on their own time and under their own
circumstances can get that information
right now they can't do that it's it's
buried in the line items of the budget
which may be in a spreadsheet on the SA
website but it's very hard to for a
single voter to figure out what's what
in that spreadsheet so it would be great
if every voter had the the time the
energy the wherewithal to attend all
these budget hearings but the reality is
not very many people do ask a follow up
please follow up and where you
referenced um that there's a bill that
was passed last year that goes into
effect this coming
summer even Even If This Were to go on
warp speed and be on next week like if
we were to vote on it today and get it
onto next week's calendar which I don't
think it's even possible um and then go
I don't like how is this going to
possibly be in effect prior to the bill
for next year so it would impact the
vote on March
11th it wouldn't have any impact on this
year's voting certainly for example my
deliberative session is tomorrow night
um it wouldn't have any impact on this
year's voting but the main
distinction between this bill and the
existing statute is that this bill would
allow future voters not this year but
and maybe in 2026 to vote on the SAU
budget not just look at it but vote on
it as well representative Dr thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um as a representative for a
couple of districts that are single
school saus I just want to ask you about
the placement of commas in the word or
on line 24 and
25 so which page page
one yeah okay at a meeting held before
January 1 the school administrative unit
board or school board for single
District school administrative
units shall adopt a budget so are you
saying that if I am a single District
school administrative unit the school
board does that or do you say the school
administrative board or the school board
school well my school district and
school AD school administrative unit SAU
I guess I just I to keep from fumbling
the words um are the are the same same
single district and so the school board
conducts all of
the uh Administrative Hearings on the
budget uh so
be you're questioning whether the comma
after unit board is correct or not yes
does that phrase or school board for
single digit that means then just the
school board for the single District
saus not the choice between
administrative SAU or Schoolboard as far
as I know in my town we don't have a
separate board for the SAU we just have
a school
board yeah I think we do too
yeah okay okay fair enough thank you R
Mur thank you um Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I do have a
question with regard to um the Secretary
of State's political calendar and
Alternate town meeting days you seem to
indicate that this would not
impact any districts but there are
districts in which alternate town
meeting days do exist and they use them
so
how is that are you aware of that I
guess that if you're asking for 60 days
after passage there's quite possible
that this could affect districts this
year well I suppose that's possible
though although I will have to admit
that I find that uh improbable Since By
the time this legislation Works its way
through the
process um should it succeed in the
house and the Senate I would think it
would be July or August before it got to
the governor's desk and if the governor
assigned it
then it wouldn't take effect for 60 days
so it might take effect in October I
don't know of any towns that delay
their uh their town meeting activity
until October maybe there are some but
none that I'm aware
of thank you rep Woodcock thank you CH
well thank you for testifying um just
for Layman Clarity here in your District
um with seu in a single building like uh
Margaret so the budget would show the
SAU cost of the separate entity and then
the other school cost of this other
separate entity and this what make I'm
trying to decide from which what you
said and in my school district where
there is seu over say seven towns there'
be one seu cost and then that each
individual seven towns is that how that
would
look how is that how you fact is that
what you're
saying I believe so yes uh the cost
would be a portioned according to the
formula in the legislation for each of
the seven towns okay uh but the overall
would be singled out and then the cost
would be proportioned within the
individual schools okay I believe that's
the way it would work uh I could be
wrong there are probably other folks who
could oh that's okay I just trying to
get that
picture one more okay thank you so same
extent than going back to your town
marg's town so in your one bill one
warant out the thing that comes for the
voters there be two costs one this is
what it cost the the the community to
run the schools administratively this is
what it cost for
programming the way the bill is light
laid out basically default back to the
year before there would be two different
budgets the the SAU budget and then the
school budget right and if either failed
then they would fall back to the default
budget for the previous year okay so the
first year that this law took effect
there would be a presumably no default
SAU budget to fall back on okay um so I
suspect
the the budget if it fails still takes
effect because there would be nothing to
fall back on okay unless it fell back on
the previous year school budget in which
the SAU line items are buried that that
also likely could happen Okay thank
thank you Mr chair president
Bon thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so a a lot this
with the single District seu if I
understand it correctly you are asking
that all the superintendent duties in uh
RSA
194c SE be separated out you know any of
those superintendent duties would be
considered SAU duties in a single
District yes the way the the legislation
is worded and this is already an
existing uh law it says that the
expenses of the school administrative
unit may include the salary and expenses
of Supervisors of health phys physical
education music art and guidance and any
other employees and and shall include
the necessary expense necessary the
expenses necessary for the operation of
the school administrative unit
superintendent assistant superintendents
business administrators teacher
consultants and the regularly employed
office Personnel of the school admin
administrative unit shall be deemed
employees of the school administrative
unit followup yes um so that's confusing
to me because there are some Personnel
that have
um uh duties that kind of overlap I mean
there are say special education
administrators that also have case lows
that also I mean I don't understand how
you can effectively separate it out and
say this is how much time I spend doing
this and this is how much time I spend
doing that do you does that make any
sense that does make sense but
apparently the SAU employees can figure
this out because every year the
Department of Education requires them to
file a form E10 which uh lists all the
SAU
employees so that the part the
department is aware of them so they must
be able to figure out how to how to do
that since they have to figure fill out
E10 represent Marie thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question is
it your assumption the way the bill is
written that you could essentially have
a default budget for the SAU and a
default budget then for the academic
portion of
learning
yes thank you Mr chair just I'm I'm
still a little confused with them so if
to that last question so you have a
multi-district um seu and you have four
towns voting and my Town's budget
presumes that the seu budget is and and
it is one thing and that's included in
my Town's budget and that's what I'm
voting on but then I'm separate you're
separating out the SAU budget which is
assuming those figures as well and each
of those four towns is assuming whatever
that proportional amount is um and
say if the seu budget fails but it
passes in four
towns I mean or three of the four towns
I don't understand how that all would
budgets I believe that is spelled out
referenced by this
legislation like most legislation that
we all have to cope with and figure out
you read a bill like this and it refers
to all kinds of other legislation that's
in
existence and trying to remember what
each piece of those referenced leg
legislation refers to is is difficult
but that is spelled out I read it
somewhere
work any
further questions uh someone else might
have some uh feedback on that question
representative if I figure it out I'll
get back to
you uh thank you very much
representative
uh next we have Scott
Goffstown hi everyone my name is Scott
Grose and I'm from gtown New Hampshire
I'm the business administrator for 9
which represents cstown and New Boston
um I did have an opportunity I I don't
know what the prior versions of this
bill was uh were but I did take a look
um at the bill 564 and there's just a
lot of questions more questions than
answers um I'm also someone who serves
as an election official in my town so
I'm going to just try to hit on a couple
of issues that I find really confusing
as somebody who might have to administer
this and both as a business
administrator but also somebody who was
an election official so the first one
that I wanted to share is I do belong to
a multi-district so we have two um in
the SAU and so for us there is an SAU
budget that SAU budget is set by a
combined SAU Board of both gtown and New
Boston and in that situation because gof
toown is a much bigger Town than new
Boston um they must have what's called a
weighted vote which means that and they
also pay a whole lot more towards the sa
apportionment than these other districts
so this past year gtown paid 78% of that
SAU budget and New Boston paid
22 when you read through this piece of
legislation it talks about how the
majority of people who vote on these two
separate warrant articles would
determine whether or not that SAU budget
passes or fails so like I said before
78% gown 22% New Boston I I have the um
I pulled up a couple of town reports
this is from 2023 not last year but
interestingly in
2023 um there were
19113 people who voted in gtown for the
on the school budget and this one
surprised me in New Boston
1763 even though Gan is a much larger
town so in that example goof toown
voters would have represented
52% uh of all of the voters uh that
particular uh voting uh Year New Boston
48 my point that I'm trying to make here
is that um gtown has this weighted vote
so if they wanted a certain budget or
wanted to defeat a certain budget they
could do that by asking for a weighted
vote um in 20 some odd years of living
in the community I think it happened
once um in but in the way this is set up
new Boston as a town would get a lot
more power um and if you had whether it
be a conservative town or a liberal Town
certainly the majority in this case uh G
almost 80% uh loses quite you know could
lose out you know quite a bit in that in
that situation I wanted to also talk
about on page three uh it talks about
how ballots would be uh collected and
one thing that I'm super confused on is
that it appears as the way that this is
written for what I would call
traditional town meeting um both New
Boston and gtown are s SP2 towns um so
it doesn't really talk about
deliberative sessions or or anything
like that um but as someone who's an
elected official the one thing that got
me super nervous on this one is it talks
about how the secretary uh has to retain
the ballots and things being transported
I can tell you as an elected official
when we have paper ballots that are
going from one in gtown we have two
polling locations um one is in
Pinardville one is in gtown high school
we have the police department has to
they're the ones who are the custodians
of those ballots at the end of the night
um I used to be a select board member as
well we had to sign off on after we seal
them with red tape I mean it's some
serious stuff this I don't know how you
separate like the ballot uh from a
recount so it's super uh you know super
confusing uh in in that case um as
somebody who I might be in the minority
of people who work in this education
business I really do think that there
are inefficiencies in state government
in education um and but this I think
exacerbates that I I think it makes it a
situation more inefficient I believe
that we elect folks like you to do a job
and I hope and trust that you will do a
good job on bills and on budgets Etc we
also elect local Schoolboard members who
serve their community and then in this
case they serve on a multi-district SAU
um if the communities do not like what
the SAU budget is they will then vote
those people out and I've seen that in
both of our towns where you know people
thought that the spending was too
liberal they they uh brought on more
conservative candidates it just it it it
just it's the natural um you know cycle
of things I do want to uh think that
they're some sometimes we create laws
that uh to solve a problem that may be
either doesn't exist or can be fixed
pretty easily so I totally understand
what representative BOS was mentioning
but you can create certain codes within
your budget to determine even if you're
a single District okay this is for a
superintendent service this is for the
business part of the superintendent
there's ways to create a code if you
want to know what those amounts are and
to question those and with spreadsheets
and pivot tables and you you can slice
and dice the data you can ask all those
questions so um I do believe that there
are opportunities all across the board
with public hearings deliberative
sessions voting represent uh school
board members in and out in our town we
also have budget committees Finance
committees there's there's a lot of
checks and balances I I just think that
this particular bill um is is super
problematic also it isolates
you know one component of administration
I would argue in one of my communities
we spend more money on student
transportation than we do on
Administration but yet we don't put that
out to the voters so the um I understand
some of the reasons for this but I would
I would hope that there are other ways
of kind of solving that and I am
available to any one of you or any
representative for ideas on how to help
you get what you want but just not do it
in a way that I think makes it a whole
lot more inefficient
thank you thank you very much for being
questions representative litfield thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question so oftentimes I've heard
frustration because the Schoolboard
members the let's say The Joint Board of
the co-op they'll come together and
they'll vote on this SAU budget right
which I know you mentioned we can vote
these people out um then these weighted
amounts are passed on to the towns and
the towns feel as though they have no
actual say what can we do outside of
having some kind of a special election
just for an SAU budget to actually give
voters a say on that particular
amount uh well for one I'm not familiar
you you appear to be in a community that
has a co-op and I I'm not as part of a
co-op ours is what's called an area
agreement and um there are as part of
that agreement it it it's kind of spells
out how things are um are handled but
ENT
it is the represent representative form
of government just like it is here where
uh those things are debated I will tell
you that there are public hearings there
are discussions um about how much money
is spent on um superintendent salary my
salary they're published um I think
those are very very important to shed
light on the cost of administration and
the cost of of everything that we do um
so I do think think that um as it is
sometimes cumbersome to publish you know
certain data Etc I think that is an
effective checks and balance more so
than anything else to to highlight what
people like myself make in terms of the
contributions that we make to a certain
school districts I think that would be a
help thank
you anything further see none thank you
very much for have a good day
[Music]
thank you again chairman Cordell members
of the committee bar Christina schoolb
Association we are opposed to House Bill
564 um I I appreciate um the prime
sponsor sort of explanation of the bill
because I was thoroughly confused trying
to read through this I mean the simplest
way to put it is that a single District
SAU does not have a separate SAU
operating budget they they don't in a in
a multi-district sa you're having
multiple Towns come together to form one
school administrative unit that provides
central office services superintendent
Services special ed services business
manager Services perhaps transportation
services there may be some others for
multiple school districts um I mean
could a could a a single District
SAU carve out it its budget so it's
clear that these are the administrative
services and these are the special ed
services and these are the
transportation costs I suppose they
could I I I mean I I'm not familiar with
the budgeting software that districts
use I know that there are multiple
Department of Revenue Administration
codes that that break that that break
that down that are I presume reported to
the Department of Education or the
depart Department of of Revenue
Administration um so that's that's
that's I mean to One Challenge the other
aspect too
the bill doesn't include it it includes
the reference in RSA
194 um C that talks about um single C3
page one lines 17 through 18 single
District saus shall be considered the
same as uh single District single school
districts and be exempt from the
requirements of this chapter there's a
similar similar provision on RSA 194
that reaffirms that as provided in RSA
194 C3 single District school interative
unit shall be considered the same as a
single School District um you know so I
just
I I guess the other concern with that is
that um I'm on page one still that at a
meeting held before January
1 the school administrative unit or
School Board of a single District SAU
shall adopt a budget required for the
expenses of the SAU for the next FIS
schal year the reason that that date is
January 1st is because school districts
whether or not you're a single District
se but individual school districts are
having their budget hearings in the
middle of January so you need to know
what your SAU this the district needs to
know what its SAU costs are going to be
when it's putting together its own
District budget um that's why there's
the that date is January 1st and from my
experience most boards are getting those
SAU costs wrapped up in in in in the
fall because the districts the
constituent districts of the SAU have to
work through their budget um the other
aspect too is um we already have a
provision in law this bill would would
seek to eliminate the alternative budget
um alternative SAU budget procedures in
RSA 194 CA and C9 um if the voters of an
individual town want to separately vote
for their SAU budget and not have it
included in their General operating
budget there's a provision where that
SAU budget can go is a separate warrant
article and if it's voted down it's
almost like a default budget the the
same cost that that District paid last
year to the SAU is what carries forward
for the for the next for the next school
year so um I think Mr gross um you know
because he's sort of in in in the thick
of this and the budgeting aspect said it
much better than I but I I think this is
just going to cause confusion um we
talked about the bill um earlier um that
goes into effect on July 1 2025 where
school districts are going to have to
publish on their website all the
administrator salaries and everything I
think that and that and that applies to
every school dist our that's they use or
not so I think the information is going
to be available to to the voters and
what the administrative costs are
assuming that there's a rational way to
to to to figure those out but um I'll
stop there and and again nhsp has
opposed but we have a lot more questions
um moving forward and we we think that
we think it's very
confusing thank you very much uh
questions for Mr Christina
I see none thank you very
good afternoon members of the uh House
Education policy committee my name is
Eric power um from Brookline New
Hampshire uh I'm a former School Board
member in the hollbrook Lan Co-operative
School District I'm also the president
of the school district governance
Association of New Hampshire it's a
volunteer organization concerned about
governance and fiscal responsibility in
school districts so um what house bill
564 does is it basically makes sure that
every single Le SAU in New Hampshire
actually has a budget if you count how
many saus we have in New Hampshire it's
about it's 105 saus and of the 105 81 of
them are what they call single District
saus that means that SAU serves a single
School District that single School
District could be a co-op that could be
a regional school or an area school but
it only serves one school district so
you got to keep in mind the difference
between a school district and a town
they're not always
synonymous um in my school district
where I live in Brookline we actually
have three school districts in
sau41 we have our K through six
Brookline School District we have our K
through six Hollis school district and
then we have the 7 through 12 Hollis
Brookline Cooperative School District so
there's it's a three District
SAU so there was a question before about
how do you know who's in the SA and
every year um by October 1st the
Department of Education requires many
forms about enrollment and such but one
of those forms is the form
a2d which is uh referenced in here and
it has to tell you uh has to report into
the Department of Education who's in
your SAU and if the person is a
portioned it can be put down as a FTE if
perhaps maybe they're supported by the
SAU half of the time and then maybe by
one of the school district by half of
the time they'd be 0 five on that form
but there's no there's no mystery about
who's in the SAU um under that process
so if you have a single District SAU
they don't really have to have a budget
it just becomes part of the school
budget and I think that's the the
frustration with a lot of school
districts that are single district saus
there are a couple that do break it out
but they just don't want to break it out
for some reason in most cases um and I
put down some of the things that are
used if you looking if take I took a
sample at school districts across the
state in the single District SAU so it's
really not clear how how much you're
actually spending on the SAU so that's
77% of saus are in that category the
other 23% actually are multi-district
seus because they have to actually have
an SAU budget so if there's multi
multiple school districts they actually
have to have a separate budget because
they have to apportion it to the school
district um and that means that then
that becomes um that becomes typically a
line item in the School District budget
of the constituent uh school
districts however um so you can see it
there so for 23% they actually have a
budget um the multi-district saus have
to have uh do this process in Janu in
December because it needs to be done
before January 1st so they have a
meeting of the collective boards that
means the sa board means the school
boards of all the saus in my case
there's five five and seven so it's a 17
person board goes through that budget
budget in December and I had one time I
remember it was between Christmas and
New Year's believe it or not so how much
public input are you getting there they
vote on that they take public input and
then they set the budget they also set
what they call is an adjusted budget
it's similar to a default budget you
have under sb2 but it's for saus it's
called the adjusted budget that doesn't
happen with these single district
saus and so um for most saus AC
multi-district saus of 21 of them they
actually just make it a line item
in the uh in their operating budget for
that um for that specific SAU now there
is an alternative budget procedure that
currently exists for
saus and um and I've we've actually
adopted in sau41 there's three school
districts that are using that so in that
case the school district gets the um
gets the a portioned part of their
school district which will be a proposed
SAU budget and an adjust Ed uh SAU
budget and that goes on the warrant as a
separate warrant article but that's
enabling legislation that you have to uh
enable and it's very difficult to pass
because you have to have the school
boards agree to put it on and they
typically don't or you have to get
petitions to put it in in every school
district with the same language the same
year and have it pass and we did that
and some a few have done that but it's
not easy so this bill isn't actually
doing anything new it's just requiring
that that this procedure that we have
today that which works well and I can
talk in detail about it um be used for
all school districts so that is actually
a separate warrant article for every SAU
in every District in the state I don't
think that's too much to ask and I think
that's part of the problem is the growth
in SAU budgets is because there's this
process where the voters have very
little very little control um even under
the alternative budget procedure that
that that gives you some control and you
have some ability to what's going on so
um let's see here
so for example let talk a little bit
about how the voting works so I'll talk
about seu 41 because I'm in it we have
our Hollis bookland Co-op which is a
traditional meeting we have our Hollis
School District which which is a
traditional meeting and then we have our
Brookline School District which is s SP2
so we have a mix of these we've been
using this procedure for um and we
actually change changed the SP2 in the
Brookline School District about eight
years ago so we had traditional
traditional traditional but now we have
SP2 for one of them the process works
it's there's no mystery there everyone
knows how to do it about the ballots
you're basically trying to count up the
ballots for every single School District
so in our case there's three school
district meetings and in two of them
it's a ballot vote by a secret ballot at
the meeting under the traditional
meeting and in the brook line one it's
secret ballot but it's on the S SP2 on
Election Day so when all of the ballots
are collected the the school district
clerks get together and they put
together what the actual result is and
if it's a majority yes then the proposed
budget of the SAU is is adopted and if
it's a uh if it's less than a majority
then you get the adjusted budget similar
to what happens under sb2 with a default
budget so this isn't new it's being used
today so there's no confusion in
actually how it works what as what what
what house bill 564 does is it makes
every single um School District in the
state actually have an SAU budget and
like I said they know who's in the SAU
because of the 82d forms every year so
it's not like they have to think figure
that out so um one thing I just wanted
to mention is that just the the
motivation for this is that this bill
was proposed two years ago and um this
right now we have 18 superintendents
making 17 $7,000 or more including one
making 210,000 a year in the Oyster
River we have 61 assistant
superintendents in the state we have six
scus that have two assistants and we
have we have six scus that have two
assistants and we have two seus that
have three assistant superintendant and
I list them in here who who they are
just two years ago when we had slightly
more students we had just 10
superintendents over 170k
and we had just 51 assistant
superintendents now we have 61 so why
are we keep getting this growth because
there's not a lot of visibility into the
SAU
budget so so what is sa at the bottom
here it talks about the solution um what
does this do it ensures all seus
actually propose a known transparent SAU
budget in a separate warrant article so
that the voters can vote on it it's not
just seeing it it's actually being able
to vote on
it the um it does require the balloting
and budget procedures that are exist
today under the alternative procedure to
be used as the procedure for all school
districts and it works well it's being
used already uh in our state um what
does it require single District seu have
to update their accounting practices
they have to account for the Personnel
that are on their a2d
form multidistrict seus already have to
do that they have to determine the
adjusted budget can the adjusted budget
contains no new position services or pay
raises and the voters get to decide if
they want to pay for those or not and
then they have to actually conduct a
public budget hearing that we have today
for the uh multi-district scus all of
them would would would actually have
that hearing so it really provides
Clarity to the voter because the SAU
budget is a separate warn article it
directly empowers voters in the
districts to decide between the proposed
an SAU budget via a ballot vote and when
the SAU budget proposal get is
transparent and gets voters scrutiny
it'll tend to drive more responsible and
sustainable budgeting in our
saus and with that I'll take any
questions if folks have it on the uh on
HP
564 thank you if I could just um ask um
if you said that the uh doe 812 D form
um is not completed by single District
saus No every single School dist a2d
Alpha 12 Delta yeah okay rury uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question just for clarity I'm trying to
understand are you testifying a bit on
behalf of an organization or you uh
because you enumerate being uh uh the
president of an organization or you
testifying on your own behalf or could
could you maybe um uh give a brief
description of what the uh School
District governance Association is
School District governance Association
is a volunteer organization of members
across the state include uh including
state
representatives um and so we're no one
organization forther
questions Mr chair yes represent Freeman
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr Po
for coming in front of us and just to
kind of piggyback off what you just said
about the um School District uh
governance Association you're also not a
lobbying group is that correct that's
you uh looking back at the last term's
bill
um I'm trying to recall maybe you can uh
refresh my memory in terms of some of
the um issues that uh came up in the uh
testimony with that prior
bill I think that people didn't quite
understand and what the bill did I think
that was there was a there wasn't a lot
of time to explain it um it there was a
Senate bill I think it was Senate Bill
155 if I remember correctly um and so
there wasn't the opportunity to
understand it and I think when people to
understand things they want to vote no
on things so I think that's where it was
but I think we've continued to see the
uh growth in administrative costs so I
think it's becoming a more and a more
highin
item thank you represent Bon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um just to clarify
you you have said that the procedure to
do this is already in statute um you're
just taking away uh the ability for the
it representative we're not taking well
we're we're not taking it this it's
complicated for a second little back up
so today the enabling legislation that's
available is only available for
multi-district saus so if you're in the
77% of saus you do not have that option
if you're in the 23% I guess I could say
yes but you're not going to take away
the option to do it you're going to be
able to utilize that directly it's a
very difficult uh RSA to adopt because
it has to be voted in by all the school
year and um which sa which RSA was you
were you referring to just now in that
answer chairman it's um the RSA that's
there now is the alternative budget
procedure I think it's
RSA 194 C9 a
b or na A and B I think okay I think
once the adoption of it one's the actual
use ofage of it
right so that becomes the becomes
something everyone uses instead of so
it's proven it's not a new thing it's
already being used
today right I think there was a prior
question um uh about um if there were if
the SAU costs are proportioned
out um to each of the
districts um so that each there's let's
say three
towns and each town has um an item um in
their budget for SAU costs for their
Town um what happens if two towns pass
their share of the SAU budget and one
town does
not chairman lad I mean chairman uh
cordelli sorry used to the other
committee um so the um the way it works
it's not really Town although it could
be town it's really member school
districts yes so if you have a if you
have a multi- toown co-op you have a
single district meeting that would be a
warn article at that meeting um but the
way it works is you take the so for
those who aren't aware a portion of SAU
costs by default is 50% average daily
membership 50% equalized valuation it's
kind of like a co-op but that's the
that's the formula that's used for
apportioning the costs uh across the
school
districts just last year there was a
bill that allowed that formula to be
different um so they can now adopt a new
uh apportionment formula for saus if
they choose to that's adopted um by a
vote as well um
so the the choice between the adjusted
budget and the proposed budget is done
by a majority ballot vote collecting the
B the ballot yes and NOS from each of
the school districts meetings and when
the last District votes then you know
the result of the of the outcome if
that's the
question thank
you any further
questions seeing none right now thank
you very much really appreciate you
being here thank
cards yes
sir you have a uh piece of additional
information sort of I I just want to
apologize to the committee for
misidentifying the Department of
Education form as E10 it's actually a2d
I apologize for that yeah no
problem it's easy to get forms confused
around
here so we will close the
hb564 and um we can begin the hearing on
bullying and we welcome representative
McDonald to present her bill hello
hi
okay are you ready yep okay
for the record I am Valerie McDonald
representing Rockingham 25 which is my
hometown of Salem and also where my
friends and neighbors live and I'm here
as the prime sponsor of HB 108 relative
to bullying and cyber bullying across
multiple school
districts first thank you for paying
attention to this critical issue
bullying can be challenging to address
because it likely has occurred since
beginning of time and it's not as simple
as creating a law that mandates
as I'm sure you all know um we wouldn't
be able to enforce that especially among
children when we can acknowledge that
even adults struggle to be kind at times
but what we can do is remedy bullying
when it inevitably occurs and that's
what HB 108 hopes to do this year alone
there are three bills which aim to
combat bullying one is actually going to
be heard after this bill um but they
each come from a different perspective
hp1 orwe specifically does not conflict
with either so if the committee decided
it could be passed alongside either bill
without any conflict furthermore the
other two bills examine the big picture
whereas HB 108 focuses on the more
nuanced issues of cross District
bullying as well as cyber
bullying being the only Bill to address
these specific issues it would have a
tremendous benefit to the well-being and
as well as the mental health of New
Hampshire
students unfortunately this is not a
proactive measure although I really wish
it was in reality students have had
access to advanced technology for the
better part of two decades so the future
that past legislatures could only dream
of is already here and in large part has
already happened so we are behind in
addressing cyber bullying but I don't
think that's really the legislator's
fault because the technology has rapidly
Advanced but the legislature is
obligated to mitigate the risk to our
students and that's what I hope to do
today
after all the technology will continue
to advance leaving students even more
vulnerable to cyber
bullying um the heartbreaking story of
one of those students inspired a bill
which was placed in interim Study last
year but a consensus on how to move
forward was never reached which
indicated that further deliberation was
needed and this session I brought this
bill forward to do just that and I look
forward to collaborating in a bipartisan
manner to reach that consensus and thus
a solution for this student her family
and for the State of New Hampshire
specifically I ask you to draw your
attention on the bill to lines 9 through
11 they read in cases of bullying and or
cyber bullying across multiple School
Districts The District where the action
originated is responsible for the
investigation end quote this sentence
answers a question that current law
leaves
ambiguous who investigates the claim
once we suspect bullying has already
occurred by putting this best practice
into law we would greatly increase
accountability however if the committee
would rather the other District be
responsible to the investigation I'm not
opposed to that either I just think it's
important that we put a responsibility
in law regardless of who it is the law
should clearly State who that entity is
in fact I have spoken with um New
Hampshire school boards Association so
nhba as well as
nhsaa and they are in the early stages
of drafting an amendment from what I
have seen I'd be open to the changes
they propose and I understand that they
will both be testifying today as well
but finally I know this is not the
finance committee but it is worth noting
that this bill does not have a fiscal
impact whatsoever but considering the
financial side in the context of
bullying I will leave you with an
anonymous quote which is kindness is
free to give but Priceless to receive
thank
you thank you thank you for the quote as
well
uh questions representative
celik thank you and thank you for taking
my question and as you know the next
bill is the one that I've sponsored
relating to data around this issue um in
the work that I did last summer with the
a special committee about juveniles who
commit misdemeanors with a Target focus
on hate crimes one of the things that
became clear with a number of these
incidents is that they um sometimes get
escalated to the level where police need
to be involved in the investigations
beyond the school districts themselves
um especially where students who may not
be or children who may not be in a
school a public school setting are
involved in the cyber bullying and so
I'm curious in in those circumstances
because obviously police investigations
have a cost right so there then would be
a fiscal note attributed to it but also
where you have circumstances where
perhaps the cyber bully is someone who's
not attending a school system where you
see having an investigative Authority
and if you thought about that component
of it if there's a way we could amend
this to address those
circumstances um or for example if you
know if it originated let's say at my
house would I be responsible for
investigating the issue with my child
right because I'm home if I chose to
homeschool my child I'm not a school
district right so I'm just trying to
understand how that would come together
I'm sorry it's complicated no understand
the question and I'd like to thank you
for that but also for your bill and
you're addressing this issue from
another angle I do appreciate it in
terms of that question if the police
were to be involved I understand there
could potentially be a cost to doing
that um the LBA did not note that in
their um amount of the bill I imagine
that would be a more rare circumstance
it would probably be negligible but it
could perhaps amount to a cost I would
agree with that
assessment um the way the bill is WR now
it does say where the action originated
um the district where the action
originated so I'm unaware of the impact
that would have on homeschoolers but
that's definitely something that the
committee may want to look at I would
agree and as I said I am open to
amending language I have spoken to the
school boards Association and it is not
written in the form of an amendment for
OS yet but I imagine if the committee
wanted to go in that direction I could I
could arrange that to happen but on that
Amendment they say that the principal of
the district or their design shall be
responsible for making sure the can um
investigation is conducted if they
believe that the police needs to get
involved it be their perview not that
the principal has to do the
investigation themselves just that they
find somebody to do so and that that is
their responsibility hope that answers
the
question thank you rent Murray thank you
Mr shair thank you for taking my
question um and thank you for bringing
the bill forward um in in an instance
where perhaps um things cross state
lines or it's later determined that um
some exists I'm I'm curious how you
would determine with cyber bullying
initially where the locus of it is
originating from without an
investigation um sometimes that is hard
to determine and and sometimes it's
never determined and it's so I'm curious
to know how you would navigate that
conversation as well okay so this bill
as I mentioned um comes from a bill
filed last term and that was because
specific instance where we did know
where the action originated it was one
particular student over I believe the
the application they use with Snapchat
sending pictures and um to be frank
somewhat even sexual remarks to a young
girl um to my recollection the young
girl was a recent immigrant so there was
a language Bearer as well so it's
picking on somebody who doesn't
understand so it seems to me even more
heart-wrenching and this is a solution
to that scenario I'm not sure how it
would impact if we don't know where this
the situation is so again I'd be open to
working with the committee to answer
questions like that if the bill um to
your recollection does not answer that
already then I'd be happy to make it
more
clear represent
B thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
for taking my question um cyber bullying
is a is a big problem I think we can all
acknowledge that and some of the issues
that have been brought up are
problematic and and mine was kind of
along the same
lines what if there's sometimes like a
lot of these I'm thinking of pictures
being sent and um it involves multiple
children uh students or children some
might be in private school some might be
in public school um and I that to me is
is another complication with that with
with this and I agree it's something
that should be addressed um I'm just
wondering if that's might be something
that you've talked about in terms of an
amendment or how to how to make that
work thank you thank you for the
question I have not considered that
particularly um but I am open to again
having that discussion in my my goal
today is to have this um please correct
me if I'm wrong but I in speaking with
chairman cordelli I understand since
there are several bullying bills that we
will have a work session in regards to
these bills where a lot of those issues
could be worked out and again if that is
what's needed for this to pass I'd be
open to that type of amendment as
well correct I I think we will have
further discussions on this uh topic uh
as a committee um possibly as a full
committee work session um in the uh your
future um represent Woodcock you had a
question yeah thank you CH thank you for
bringing this forward and keeping the
concern Uh current clearly um two
questions last year um I remember
similar as you were talking before
representative lad had the question of
the New Hampshire Veron border yes um
and how does that work here if the
Vermont border was the the action
occurred and in the youngst in Hampshire
school I don't I don't figure how it's I
don't see the answer here but I remember
that question from last year I didn't
know if over the summer of the study
that it was resolved thank you for the
question I would note that
representative lad is a co-sponsor of
the bill so if he were to still have the
concern I imagine it's been addressed
again you'd have to follow up with him
I'm not trying to speak for him I my
district is on the Massachusetts border
so I would imagine we have a similar
concern um we the state of New Hampshire
does not have any cross districts
districts that are on the Massachusetts
border where we do contract with I
believe in St John's buy Vermont that's
not the same case in Massachusetts but
um I see the potential for that my goal
with this legislation if it's not
exactly as worded is to put something
into law that addresses this and we say
clearly who is responsible so we're not
passing the bck so there is
accountability and we know who is doing
this if this wording isn't exactly
correct then I'm willing to put in the
work to make this happen and collaborate
with I need to to get this accomplished
right okay and I think if I remember
correctly U you described the incident
that uh initiated the bill last year and
I think it was a question of um who is
going to investigate it and neither
School wanted to uh take on that role
and uh that initiated a lot of
discussion um at the state level as well
yes unfortunately neither District was
owning up to this perhaps because of the
expense or to do so and so I just wanted
to put something into law so that
student isn't vulnerable because no
adults are taking responsibility as they
should representative sell thank you um
Mr chair and and thank you for bringing
this forward um earlier this year I
received a heartbreaking email from uh
one of our someone in the state not from
my district but whose son was a victim
of cyber bullying through snapchat he's
a child with special needs and someone
created a fake account of his which then
he got got in trouble for and he was
sent to a different District where the
people who created the account are
currently having no consequences for
their behavior and so I just would
invite us when we get to our work
session to Think Through not just the
who
investigates but how can we create some
sort of appropriate but not
discriminatory aspect of consequences
for some of this behavior and it's
really complicated as I'll get into when
we get to my bill next but um I do know
that parent I mean like it will
literally make you cry if I share the
details of the things that she sent to
me so yes we've um heard a number of
cases since I've been here of of Bing um
and uh suicide um that uh you know are
heart-wrenching for sure yeah so um yeah
it's something I definitely want us to
take a look at as a committee see what
we can uh Advance um uh to the house
FL represent of Woodcock this maybe your
Workshop as well um I'm confused about
the term action
originated only to the extent
representative of me clear to me was
victim and perpetrator victim like that
so if if the action for example was two
victim in the
same was there as well as a victim in
that
school say a dance okay and that night
that's where the hit the
pan it was there they go back this peret
goes back to the school that that's what
getting confused that little there maybe
something represent wants to dialogue in
the workshop that that's having a high
time with those terms versus victim
victim okay um me I'm my intention was
not to include words such as victim or
perpetrator because that almost implies
the result of the investigation before
it happens to say this person did
something when we don't know that to be
true kind of goes against innocence
until proven guilty which is why I
settled on the words action originated I
understand and your concern my intention
with this is the district the student
attends if the action occurred perhaps
at a school dance like you mentioned I
wouldn't see that as the district the
student attends if it's an outof
District student but that's how I would
read this thank
you
Paul Mr chair and this is more of a
point I think than a question but as we
talk about out of state know we're
talking about neighboring St Johnsbury
neighboring Massachusetts it could be
not neighboring Kansas right it could be
anywhere I mean to suggest that it's
even just across the border you know
cyber bullying can happen anywhere so
adds another layer to this yes gu that
wasn't would you believe yes I would
believe that doesn't surprise me in the
slightest bit um as it's been noted by a
few of you it's definitely a complicated
issue and that's something that should
be considered but it would be remiss not
to do anything just because it's
difficult that's not an excuse for us
not to act right thank
you any further
questions see none thank you very much
thank you for your
Perez welcome to education again or
education
policy thank you thank you committee
members thank you chairman cardelli this
was my bill last year and I presented it
to you all
and um I was thrilled to hear when um
representative McDonald was going to
bring it forward and it seems that a lot
of the same questions um are coming up
again and
um the story that was from last year
just had to was heart-wrenching it was a
woman a young girl who lived in
um District a
District B had a young man who had a
relative in District um a said hey
there's this fat ugly immigrant
here and this guy started harassing her
and calling her names and sending
pictures and that type of thing
unfortunately it's my understanding that
nothing happened to
that be and
it's heart-wrenching to think the the
young girl actually was so traumatized
by this she was out of school for like
two weeks I believe before she could
return to
school this is about the kids and cyber
we all know cyber building is so out of
control it's out of control for
adults as well as for children but my
concern is this is year two that we are
bringing this forward and we cannot
continue to Kick Kick the Can down the
road until something
extremely traumatic happens bullying
does cause children to commit suicide
cyber bullying is makes it so easy for
them as far as finding out who did it
the one good thing about cyber bullying
is they really technically can find out
who the perpetrator was whereas
verbal bullying in the school it's a
more of a he said she
said that's why this is so out of contr
troll because they think that they don't
have to the kids you know they don't
have to face the person they can just be
horrendous to them I really would like
to see and I know there's a lot of
questions about it and so you work them
out you find them you decide what's the
important thing we've changed laws I
mean if we find that one this isn't
perfect when we when you hash it around
we can look at maybe making it more
perfect but it can't be kicked down the
road anymore we can't lose any more
children to suicide because of bullying
and this is about the kids totally 100%
so thank you for listening I'd be happy
to take any questions thank you very
much representative any questions
representative Balon uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um something that you said just
kind of uh struck me as a the schools
can only do so much in terms of you know
tracking these things you I mean
bullying is an all pervasive problem
that involves other people in a in a in
a student's life so I would hope that
when we're looking at these bullying
bills we look at more a
comprehensive uh solution to the problem
so and I agree with you we need to do
something about it thank you yes we
really need to do something now and
that's my so that's why any other
questions no no see none thank you very
much
thank you chairman cordelli good
afternoon members of the committee bar
Christina school boards Association I
know it's been a long day for everybody
I know you've got at least one more
hearing I will try and be brief uh
School boards Association is in full
support of House Bill
108 um I did email um representative
McDonald uh yesterday we connected
briefly um earlier this morning um I was
being passed around is a proposed
amendment that the School Board
Association drafted up um I think trying
to stay um with what representative
McDonald's intent was um when you have
bullying across multiple school
districts and whose responsibility is it
to investigate um again we haven't had a
chance to do a deep dive into this but
I'll just read it briefly it's the it's
the language and bold in front of you in
cases of bullying or cyber bullying
across multiple School Districts The
principls or principles designate
of all districts involved shall be
responsible for conducting an
investigation in such investigations the
principales or design are encouraged to
collaborate relative to their respective
investigations um you know from our
perspective it doesn't matter where the
kids are if one kid is from conquered
and the other kid is from hookset and it
occurred at the mall and Manchester and
it gets reported to those principles
those principles have an obligation to
at least do something make some phone
calls do an investigation talk to the
witnesses whatever your bullying proc
whatever your bullying investigation
procedures are they're very
comprehensive in the statute they're
very comprehensive in the nsba policy so
again um if there's a committee um uh a
subcommittee or whatnot um and and there
tweaks to this language on hsba will
certainly help in whatever way we can I
I hope you sort of caught your intent
representative McDonald with what you're
trying to do not married to this
language if there need to be tweaks
we're happy to help um but again uh we
wanted to to sort of make sure that I
don't I don't care who the students are
if you're a principal and it comes to
your attention you have an obligation to
at least do something about it so with
that I'm happy to to answer any
questions thank you representative the
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I appreciate this
language um my fear is that if you give
a job to a committee Nobody Does it and
and I wonder if you could combine this
by saying maybe the the district where
it origin at initiates the cooperation
so that somebody starts the process yeah
certainly thank you for the question
representative again further
conversation needs to be had I think
hopefully we we can we can flush that
out we'd be certainly agreeable or
amendable to something along those lines
whatever language can come out so we
make sure that again who I don't I don't
care where the kids are from if a
principal receives a report of that they
have an obligation to do something call
their principal in the neighboring
School talk to the person that filed the
report with them whether or not that
comes from a parent a student a witness
maybe the person that informed the
principal was not even involved in it
but saw it and was concerned about it so
reported it to the principal that
principal has an obligation to do
something even if it's just call your
neighbor down the road in the other
school even though it wasn't my district
but my my child in my district saw it
with other kids in other districts that
principal should have an obligation to
make a phone call so the ball gets
rolling and and and it's it's dealt with
accordingly thank you um
if I could ask one question thank you um
uh where and when and how do you see
Parental involvement in this when when
is the parent contacted I know there's
um statutes involved currently and uh
there's a something like a 48h hour
period right to uh conduct an
investigation before the parents uh are
notified um
based on a waiver request by the
superintendent yeah that's something
along those lines sure thank you for the
question representative excuse me a
second um I'm not trying to dodge the
question to some degree that might be
more an administrative uh somebody an
administrator could answer as I'm sure
you're aware there are 10 references to
the word parent in the statute the
policy has to have a procedure for
notification within 48 Hours of the
intendent report to the parent or
parents or guardian of the of the victim
vitim of bullying or cyber bullying and
the parent are parents of the guardian
of of the perpetrator you know I mean 48
hours I guess we can debate whether or
not that's sufficient whether the the
parent should be known by the end of the
day to some degree it may be you know
circumstance specific how severe was the
action how severe was the allegation is
the principal perhaps not in the
building that day and it was reported to
an assistant principal um you know it it
if if an investigation is undergoing is
being under undertaken I understand the
desire for the parents to be informed
but sometimes you know things need to
settle out with the administrators and
talk to people before you know a
judgment is made to call call the parent
it may be it may be a rumor maybe
nothing happened you know and so there's
going to be some level of administrative
discretion um if it's significant
obviously if it's cyber bullying if it's
something that relates to um what would
be um illegal or improper
discrimination you know sexism racism
whatever it might be I think there's
probably an obligation to call call the
parent you know your your kid said these
words in the locker room so I hope that
answered it somewhat right um in your
view um if there is sexism MH invol or
racism
involved um would would you
classify um that as
bullying or human rights violation uh do
you have an idea where that line is
because I know of a
situation and my understanding is the
children have actually left school
because of it yeah thank you for the
question representative I I I can as as
as a lawyer but not a practitioner I
can't give a clear answer to that I will
tell you though that when the law became
effective I 2010 or 2011 when the
blowing law became effective that was a
question that a lot of the school law
attorneys were having and I you know I
think and I think the the the standard
practice right now let say racism is
that an investigation is going to cover
both it's not Title 9 Title 9 would be
sex discrimination but it's going to
title think title 7even perhaps and your
local District bullying investigation
that's certainly the safest way for a
school district right to proceed so
you've got your basis has covered on the
the the federal or state discrimination
aspect but also the bullying aspect as
well too some of that I also think to
again not this maybe more for an
administrative aspect it may be the age
of the child as well too an 8-year-old
child drops an inappropriate racial slur
maybe different than a 17-year-old kid
saying the same thing and the context in
in in which it's said but I I certainly
there was a there was a a situation in a
school district probably 10 or 12 years
ago and I I say this not jokingly by any
means not not not light of it it was it
was the perfect plaintiff it was a child
of color who was a child with
disabilities who was being bullied
relentlessly um and unfortunately in
that case the district did not um do
their due diligence and the office of
Civil Rights
was on them significantly for a number
of years making sure they have policies
procedures training training place so
long with it answer representative if if
if if a district if a superintendent or
principal called me and said these are
the general facts and it involved a
protected class and bowling I'd say do
both investigations to make sure you're
covered yeah thank you yeah represent
Woodcock your turn thank you sir um very
represent I mean
attorney thank you hey you works too
yeah except for chairman right call him
chairman lad
as regards uh the issue that was brought
up uh basically Maine yeah New Hampshire
I mean Maine Vermont Massachusetts
depending where the bordering towns are
right does your uh fellow Associates or
does is there done of the one of you in
Maine and Vermont in mass or are you the
singular in terms of Association and are
there cooperate agreements standing do
you know about thank thank you for the
question representative there there is a
main Association of school committees
there's a main Association of school
boards as zont school boards Association
we I mean we we collaborate but not in
this realm I don't I'm not aware of any
sort of Interstate Compact that
addresses bullying you know it's sort of
an interesting concept if you will now
relative I don't remember the bill
hearing last year I either wasn't here
or perhaps at another hearing um and and
kids from St John's Berry kids from
Monroe um New Hampshire and some other
communities I believe kids of St John's
Berry's Academy over the Border you know
you know I I can't speak to Vermont
bullying laws I presume St John's Berry
academy is subject to to those laws but
let's say here's let's let's give me
I'll use representative McDonald sort of
Hometown let's say that a child or
student from Salem is um at the is at
the Rockingham Mall that's in Salem with
a a child from
Kingsboro you know and and and the the
child from Salem reports to to his or
her principal I was bullied at the
Rockingham Mall the kid is at Tings Boro
High School I would hope that the Salem
principal might pick up the horn and
call that individual from from T you
know the principal in Kingsboro but
according to under New Hampshire law
there certainly the Salem school
district will not they may have an
obligation to investigate they probably
should at least look into it but they
certainly wouldn't have any jurisdiction
over the kid in Kingsboro
to Levy any punishment or and and and
vice versa if the if the alleged bully
was from Salem and the the the the the
um the victim was from out of state you
know they they the out of state
Massachusetts wouldn't have any
jurisdiction to do anything to the to
the to the New Hampshire
student yeah thank you just to follow up
on that
um since you're closer to the main
border the
um New Hampshire Main Interstate School
compact is RSA uh 200
F1 and the remont compact is a 200
B1 so those are things we could look at
as a in in a work U study thank
you yes repres muray thank you Mr Sharon
thanks for taking my question it
occurred to me that while we were
talking about this sort of um
theoretical situation that you were
referencing here you were talking about
something that may have occurred outside
of school
hours um so I I I guess what I was
curious about is when would this Clause
kick in at any time the districts would
get involved or is this only at school
sanctioned events and under school hours
when the alleged incident was occurring
sure thank you for the question
representative this is RSA
193 DF Frank col 4 paragraph
1 bullying or cyber bullying shall occur
when an action or communication as
defined in RSA
193f col 3A occurs on or is delivered to
school property or a school sponsored
event or an event on or off property off
school property excuse me or B occurs
off of school property or outside of a
school sponsored activity or event if
the cont interferes with a pupil's
educational opportunities or
substantially substantially disrupts the
orderly operations of a school or School
sponsored activity or event so if the
bullying occurs it's Saturday night at
the pizza parlor and it's not a school
sponsored event but the the alleged
victim is afraid to come to school on
Monday or whatever that would inter
substantially conduct that would
interfere with a pupil's educational
opportunity
likewise if the event was on say a
weekend off school property at a
non-school sponsored event the movie
theater let's say if Monday morning
everybody comes in and every kid is
talking about it and the principal hears
about it the teachers hear about it they
know it's been posted on social media
and the kids are not focusing an
argument can be made that that would
again this is B substantially disrupt
the orderly operations of the school or
School sponsored activity or event so
the school district not only could look
at it they have an obligation to look
into
it thank you any further questions
repres Corell thank you thank you for
taking my question so to get back to
what um R Paul said what what if it's
like cyber bullying across the unit yeah
I mean get
off let's look at the adult let's look
at the adults first in that situation
and maybe everybody log off for the
weekend and you know I just you know I
don't I I can't we can't control a kid
from Kansas you know what I'm saying you
report that you know if the if the you
know alleged victim is from New
Hampshire and they report it to their
principal what that indiv what that
principal can do I have I have no idea
that's you
enforcement I I'm currently being
threatened with a ransom scam wow um for
someone who has my ID wow I my password
wow um and wants money from me um so
I've reported it to the local police and
uh I'm watching my phone to see if uh
some of his threats come to fruition
right um so yeah there's all forms of
bullying how's your Bitcoin portfolio
look exactly what that is he gave me his
Bitcoin account that he wants to deposit
it in but best of luck sir
yeah um great thank you very much for
your input
Fu thank you Mr chairman Jerry FW New
Hampshire Association of school
administrators I will be brief um we
want to speak in support of any
legislation that helps uh assisting the
issues of bullying and cyber bullying in
our schools um we appreciate the
sponsors efforts to bring this forward
happy to work with this committee or any
committee uh and any number of bills
that are uh emerging around uh the issue
of bullying to bring Common Sense
workable practical solutions to uh the
problem so that um we're not spending
time resources and energy uh every year
having these conversations
um we can work toward it I also would
like to just point
out whatever uh enrollment statistics
you want to use of however many students
we have in the state 101 151,000 U
155,000 160,000 whatever it is I do want
to submit that our school district
Personnel effectively
and efficiently investigate hundreds of
allegations of bullying each year and
they're successfully resolved I know
that as a legislative committee uh you
hear some of the and and I'm not
dismissing them or or in any way
diminishing the SE severity of them you
hear the worst and you should and we
should be acting to alleviate all of
those things the fact of the matter is
also that school administrators
investigate resolve successfully
hundreds of bullying incidents and those
are on file with the Department of
Education so um with that I will
stop thank you very much yes there are
um bullying reports uh and ually number
of incidents um by school um uh by uh
grade level and uh
category um that are all
available thank you very
much uh yes
sir
yes thank you Pro I'm the same thing I
asked Barrett does your Association uh
collaboratively uh with the other states
is there any reciproc in terms of
understanding between the superintendent
if I get at Massachusetts like in the
Salem calls is there is there anything
there that that's informal or there is
formal or should be between the
superintendents of multiple States thank
you for the question representative
Woodcock nothing formal that I'm aware
of um again uh it could be a good Common
Sense approach but I'm sure that it
would vary from uh District to District
um that you know they have those State
those Interstate issues but I'm not
aware anything and uh or conversation
about it thank you thank you very
much seeing no further questions we'll
close that
hearing um and according to the schedule
we have a few minutes until House Bill
673 and continuation of our discussion
of
bullying
yeah I was thinking that since we've had
a thorough discussion on this one it
one
um
e
ready um we'll
uh conclude our day with House Bill
673 which is relative to school bullying
and discrimination
plans and um I call on uh representative
s thank you so much um for the record I
am Lauren selig I represent straford
County District 10 which is the town of
Durham um and it is part of the Oyster
River School District which is a
Cooperative School District which
comprises the towns of Durham Lee and
Madbury with um high school students
tuition in from barington as part of a a
multi- toown compact with
barington
um in my um first term as a
representative I served on the criminal
justice committee and a number of things
occurred one is we were hearing about
increased incidents of juveniles who
were being sentenced to various forms of
the judicial system um for different
different levels of crime different
types of incidents at the same time we
were also hearing across the state about
progressively more incidents of hate
crimes occurring and hateful acts and I
want to be very clear about the
distinction between a hate crime and a
hateful act because um the Attorney
General's office gave me a 45 minute
detailed description of the difference
between the two so there are things that
we would consider hateful but that may
not Elevate to the level of a crime and
and so this bill does not talk about
hate crimes it talks about hateful acts
for a reason um while all of that was
happening I started reading about um
diversion programs that were working in
other states to help young people who
made poor decisions not continue to make
poor decisions um particularly Howard
County Maryland where I used to be a
teacher um which is a very diverse
School District when they instituted a
Teen Court program the teens who were
referred to that Court program had only
a 5% recidivism rate um which is amazing
right and and ideally we would find ways
to not have more children enter our
judicial system because if they enter as
young people the likelihood that they're
going to continue to end up in the
judicial system as adults is much higher
um and so if we can identify way so in
the previous session I created a I
worked we created a study committee to
look at juveniles who commit
misdemeanors especially hate crimes and
how we could redirect them to Diversion
programs or other methods we worked um
it was a a voluntary study committee we
had four members appointed unfortunately
two of them were not reelected which is
why they are not co-sponsors on the bill
um but we worked collaboratively um and
opened the meetings up so that we had
members from the ACLU from the Attorney
General's office from the um the current
Juvenile Diversion programs from the
office of the child advocate from uh
Children and Youth and Family Services
all came together and we worked
collaboratively and talked about the
different issues and what was going on
the biggest challenge that came up
and um was confirmed when a
representative from the Department of
Education attended our meeting is that
we lack data we have a huge gap in data
of what's happening so technically prior
to the pandemic school districts were
directed to create plans to address
bullying there wasn't an end date by
which they had to have their plan
completed they just were directed to
create the plan um and then they were
supposed to report data to the
Department of Education unfortunately
the data that's being reported to the
department isn't complete and isn't easy
to find if if you can find it's really
tricky it took me I think two and a half
hours to figure out how to get to it on
the website and I'm a relatively
proficient Searcher online you know I'm
not the best I defer to my children who
are far faster at locating
information um but when the
representative from the Department of
Education came to our meeting and said
well we've got this database
I looked at my own school district and
it reflected zero incidences of bullying
for the district which I knew
specifically was not accurate because my
child was one of the victims of bullying
in our district and we had documentation
around that so clearly there was a gap
if it wasn't reported to the state right
um additionally uh um Deputy uh attorney
general Shan lock from the Attorney
General's office specifically their
division of civil rights crimes was part
of our committee and he identified
looking at the list that there were 10
Towns where he had Active cases pending
related to bullying incidents specific
bullying incidents all of which had
reflected zero data on the state's
website so there's a gap right and so we
were trying to figure out how could we
design programs or increase or support
programs if we don't actually know where
the needs are and which areas there are
we know that there's a significant
difference in how youth are adjudicated
whether they live in the North country
or whether they live on the Sea Coast
based on the resources of those
districts and what's available but we
don't have any statistical data that
shows what the ratios and percentages
are so that's sort of the background of
this bill so we started talking about
well what could we do based on this
previous bill that would help us create
the data so that we could revisit the
issue in a couple of years and look at
what would be the best way to serve the
needs of our our children to identify
the problem address it and hopefully
remedy it so the structure of the bill
requires um and I did speak with the you
know the school administrators
Association who prefer it would be every
year as opposed to every semester for
reporting but that at the end of every
semester the school districts would have
to report their bullying incidents to
the state the state would then have a
prescriptive amount of time at the doe
to collate all of that data and have it
on a very easily publicly accessible
website and also share the link of their
data to the AG's office for the purposes
of Data Tracking because if for example
we discover that in um I don't know in
Salem people discriminate against those
who like The Color Purple which happens
to be my favorite color but we've have a
history of incidents against people who
like The Color Purple in Dairy and we
can't figure out why but then perhaps in
Portsmith we have the a history where it
shows people used to discriminate
against people who like the color green
and they've remedied it well what did
they do in Portsmouth and can we
replicate that in other districts can we
work through those things but without
having the data that shows the trends of
when bullying incidents are happening
and who's being targeted it's really
hard to know how to create structures
and programs to try to remedy it whether
it's through education whether it's
through diversion programs or other
methods so the goal of this is really
about Gathering the data and having a
structure but it's also looking not just
at bullying incidents and reported
bullying incidents but hate-based
incidents so in my kids high school
people were drawing swastikas on the
bathroom walls and writing things like
kill the
nword um right that's technically not
bullying technically it's actually not
even a hate crime although we would all
consider it a hate-based incident right
um so the part of this is directing the
doe to give the school districts a form
that has a drop- down menu that
identifies what protected classes are
being targeted in incidents such as
those right so swastica obviously are
targeting people who are Jewish people
who are minorities people with
disabilities you know and the other one
is obviously targeting people of um who
are black or of African-American descent
right um but so because that data is not
segregated out or compiled in any way
it's really hard to know how to address
it and how to move forward so that's
where the the rationale behind the bill
came from as you'll see we're still
waiting for a fiscal note I did request
a fiscal note I knew to request a fiscal
note I requested the fiscal note in
September um hopefully we'll get the
fiscal note soon um but I obviously I
can't make the fiscal note happen sooner
because we don't have it um but that's
where that's where the rationale for all
of this came from and then just if I
could read one
comment um from another parent who
reached out to me um she said I'm a
parent of a public school students and a
member of my District School Board the
Viewpoint is mine alone but we need
stronger reporting enforcement and
clarification of anti-bullying policy
and procedures to help guide and support
efforts by school districts to
appropriately address and mitigate
incidents at schools requiring specific
reporting standards will help districts
form appropriate policies and procedures
to respond proactively rather than
reactively to bullying and cyber
bullying and this parent obviously
supports the intent of the bill so and
again I'm open to amending it as we work
on our subcommittee or our special
Workshop thank you very much
representative
questions represent dry thank you and
thanks for taking my question first I
just need to clarify you said there's a
difference between a hate crime and a
hateful act and I didn't catch the
difference right
so
um freedom of speech
laws allow people to use very what we
would consider very hateful words
legally
if they use those words in a way that is
specifically threatening someone you
know like I'm going to kill you because
you're a fill-in the blank that becomes
a hate crime because it's actually the
threat of
assault that is the
crime um and it adds based on Federal
and State law there's because it uses a
targeted language or targets a
particular group that makes it a hate
crime rather than just a an assault
right
um but drawing swastikas on uh property
the crime is graffiti but the swastika
is
not the hate is is the is
not right does that make I know it's
it's so nuanced and ultimately I would I
can find the presentation um attorney
lock sent us which was as I said he
spent 40 minutes explaining all the
different nuances and technicalities and
it was a lot um but it's there's a
really fine line before something is
elevated to a hate crime um and that's
actually by State Statute it's an add-on
to an existing crime it's not a crime on
its own whereas a hateful Act is a
generally accepted term
okay okay um so I I see that you want to
maybe submit things to the ATT of
General's office of civil rights is
there nothing in that has schools
already doing that you think that that
would be a place that they would send
these things not unless it elevates to
the point of a police involved
investigation and so um if an incident
Rises to the level that the police are
brought in to investigate then either
the town or the county or the state AG
would be involved in that process but
part of the challenge for um part of the
reason for wanting to send the the
compile data to the AG's office is
really to be looking at Trends so for
example we know we have some groups that
have um like you know we have a friend
who likes to send me what I offer to as
Love Letters from his white supremacy
organization to tell me how much he Ador
me um and my policies um and
um he he walks that line very carefully
so that it's not the level of hate crime
it's it's not a crime what he sends to
me um it's certainly hateful language
and hateful
comments um and I'm not the only one who
gets his love letters um to be truthful
so
um but if we know that we have one of
these groups that sort of seems to be
growing in a particular part of the
state and we're seeing a corresponding
number of incidents in that school
district we might know about refocusing
some of the instruction or some of the
policies we're doing in that District
it's really about trying to look for the
trends right and so if we know that
Oyster River has 2,000 incidents in you
know a year and that conquered has zero
incidents so first of all is conquered
reporting accurately but if they are
what are they doing that's so successful
at avoiding these incidents and what's
happening in Oyster River not just
within the schools but within the
community that they may need to take a
deeper look at right maybe there's a
group that's been growing there and and
to be fair that's not what's actually
happening in Oyster River I'm just using
my own District so as not to impune any
other District but our district is
working hard albeit not always as
accurately as I might prefer thank
you yes represent McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you again for bringing
this forward you mentioned speaking with
the Department about this bill and I
understand there isn't a fiscal note so
the cost for this is unknown however I
know in my own speaking with the doe
whenever we have something new for them
to do in this bill they would have to
report data and have it on a website and
it seems a little bit um prescriptive
all the things that have to
do has a doe mentioned that they'd have
to have a new person to do this or hire
a new staff person to do this so
technically they're supposed to be
monitoring this already and they have a
website that's supposed to be tracking
this information when we asked about who
was responsible for actually following
up and making sure school districts
provided information or who made sure
things were uploaded the representative
who attended our meetings had no
information um so uh it became
prescriptive because we felt if you know
when we discussed this as a committee we
were like okay well someone The Buck has
to stop somewhere yes right and if
they're already supposed to be compiling
the data and they're not following
through the way that they need to be
maybe we need to be more specific about
how they compile it and that's part of
the reason for them having specific
reporting out process and a timeline
right is to say okay you got this much
time to figure it out
but let's let's get it if I may have a
followup yes and I imagine how
disappointed it is to ask a question and
the answer can't be provided for
whatever the reason is um my other
question is a bit of little unrelated
but you mentioned protected classes
beginning in line 11 and generally
speaking I'm sure we can all name what
the protected classes are but there are
VAR definitions depending on what law
you're looking at so is there a specific
definition of which protected classes
that we're referring to is it a federal
statute that's not referenced here so I
was looking at State statutes and I was
looking at the information provided by
attorney lock about what protected
classes are subject to the hate crime
statutes in our state okay and would you
think that we should specify the RSA in
here is there any added benefit to doing
that from what the attorney said I'm not
sure um we we could certainly do that
and when we have our further discussion
I'm happy to reach out and get
additional information to make sure that
I have that specific information for you
okay and if I may ask one more question
um the conclusion of my questions is
looking on beginning section um line
nine to line 10 really when you change
each school um district and chartered
public school to every school that
receive state funding my immediate
thought is what is the impact of this on
our EFA program and our EFA students so
I would hope that students who are
attending any school including the
schools that receive EFA funding that
those schools would also be reporting
bullying and uh hate incidents to the
state so that we can track them if for
example we discover that the Black
Bottle school has you know 15 students
and has 12 bullying
incidents maybe we should be looking at
whether or not that's an appropriate
place for EFA funds to be able to be
directed or if there's you know so
really it's about trying to find where
things are happening so that we can
figure out ways of addressing it all
right
thanks further
questions seen none thank you very much
uh is there anyone else who wanted to
Bill
yes is it about this bill or well the
generic Bill okay well let close this
first this it's about this bill
specifically okay um on represent
McDonald's Bill and this bill the ones
that deal with cyber bullying so you're
going to put together a work session for
that it yeah I'm I'm looking at all
three on right all three bills that
dealing with bullying okay um looking at
a work session on the morning of
February 17th it was the doe and the
AG's office going to be with that uh
sorry repres so would the uh doe
representative and the AG representative
also be involved in that um I haven't
gotten that far this just you know this
will be the first one I think we'll have
several sessions thank you so much yeah
I think we'll have several work sessions
on
this
yeah I
sorry yeah okay I'll close the hearing
on uh House Bill 673 and end um our
day